thank you
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best whoa and hey
have we mentioned there's also a million
dollars at stake the total pot is a
million dollars no that is not a typo
the prizes our unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain it's over wow Ray Robson
eat Chuckles he's not happy but he
respects the legend of ivankuk and that
Legend Continues
The cgc Knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real queen G8 check
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
chess.com Global Championship there were
64 at the start there are 38 remaining
and there will be 32 left in the
tournament after the conclusions of
today's bloody Affair covering it is
Grand Master Amman Hamilton alongside me
Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky a pleasure
to be bringing you another day of action
here at the cgc Amman welcome to the
show how are you feeling
hey Dania hello it's everyone watching I
think uh I mean not only am I excited
for every uh cgc match but today's
particularly exciting because I think we
are about to get into one of you know
most people's favorites for maybe the
entire event and also we finally get to
narrow things down from 64 to 32 players
Daniel
indeed and as we go over the overall
format it is a single elimination
knockout tournament if you lose a match
you are out each match is four games the
time control is 15 minutes plus a two
second increment per move and obviously
the first side to get to two and a half
or more wins the match if the match goes
to a 2-2 tie then we've already had
several incredibly tense armageddon's
that will decide the outcome of each
match
Amman we have a guy named Hikaru
Nakamura who will be participating today
I have a feeling as we look at the
overall bracket here that might attract
a slightly bigger viewership than normal
I don't know why I think that though
yeah it's it's a wild prediction there
but while it will certainly likely
capture a you know a great percentage of
the viewership I can also say that it
captured a great percentage of the votes
as well like icaro I mean tournament
favorite for a lot of people he's up
there at the top of the bracket as you
can see top left and uh yeah he's
looking to uh well take out uh obviously
an underdog here in Vasquez but
certainly not someone that anyone should
be counting out Daniel
no and you shouldn't be counting him out
even though yes we can see the
predictions under the player names it's
kind of looking a little bit Grim for
Grand Master Vasquez if you believe
those predictions but we were talking
before the show Rodrigo Vazquez was one
of the best Blitz players on the
internet chess club he is tremendously
experienced he is no pushover and his
title Tuesday performances have shown
that so Hikaru is definitely taking this
match seriously and so are the other two
favorites Jeffrey Zhang facing Alexander
Bortnick one of the most dangerous
players in the world especially in a
rapid time control and Fabi facing the
Italian specialist Ukrainian Grandmaster
Martin craftive Amman I think I speak
for everyone when I say we only have
three matches today but the quality of
those matches I'd rather have three of
these matches than 10. of a different
kind of match what do you say to that no
100 and obviously the uh the favorites
in these matches three American players
gonna be very familiar for our audience
is but you know important to remember
that just because these players are
underdogs I mean there's a reason that
nobody has a perfect bracket and hasn't
had a perfect bracket for a long time
Dania we see lots of upsets in in these
uh pairings so just because you see
those seedings and you see your favorite
name there everything's different when
it comes to game day who's in better
shape and who can ultimately have better
nerves if it comes down to Armageddon
right and and nothing has shown that
more than the group a bracket results we
had Eric Henson your boy defeating like
Huang Lim in incredible fashion
surviving a ridiculous roller coaster of
wins and losses to survive the
Armageddon when your Dominguez avoided
an upset
David Navara well you could say that
that was an upset but both of those
players were very similar in strength
and now it is up to Hikaru Nakamura to
join them and of course if Rodrigo
Vasquez can pull off the unimaginable
that will be the craziest upset in the
entire cgc so listen Hikaru Nakamura he
has got an x on his back and we also
want to look at the group C brackets so
does Wesley so so do all of the
favorites I'm on they don't have an easy
ride because everybody is bringing their
a game against them that always happens
yeah absolutely I mean you see the the
pairings here uh the last spot to fill
going into the next round the round of
32 is that matchup Jeffrey Zhang and
Alexander Bortnick both players
extremely active on chess.com in general
see them playing uh and competing in
title Tuesdays and very serious events
rapid chess as well fortnite so so
active so I look at those seeds and they
almost don't mean anything to me number
three number six both of these guys are
extremely competitive definitely I would
say that Jeffrey is the favorite but you
know Bortnick is is just he's got his
systems he's got his openings that he's
really good at and uh we'll see if
Jeffrey can can handle them I think this
is actually shaping up to be potentially
one of the closest matchups of this
round so keep an eye on it
for sure there's going to be some
fascinating games and finally we take a
quick look at the group D bracket yep
Vladimir FedEx and Scott akomsky the old
generation prevailing in that match got
akomski will be facing Dimitri on Drake
and but the one match yet to be played
and it will be played in just a couple
of minutes is of course Fabiano caruana
who faces Martin craft of them on
craftive maybe a less familiar name to
most of our viewers I've got two books
that he's written on the Italian on the
bookshelf behind me he's a really really
strong player he's just like a solid you
know yawn tactical 2650 player those
guys they're not pushovers no they're
they're not pushovers and in fact it's a
really difficult style to play against
because they're just Fearless it's
probably the best word for them and
that's a tough style when when your
opponent just isn't scared of what
you're gonna do I mean they'll know what
a great player Fabiano caruana is but I
don't think Martin craft stuff is going
into this match thinking that he's too
much of an Underdog he's got nothing to
lose and I think all the grand masters
of the world certainly know that he's
far from a pushover quite a strong
player and I don't think fabby's
underestimating him as an opponent
I don't think he is either and I don't
think as I said before that Hikaru
Nakamura is underestimating his Chilean
opponent Rodrigo Vasquez there is quite
the age difference vasque is one of the
older players in the field at 52 years
of age but his Blitz skill has hardly
diminished as his title Tuesday
performances have shown and he might be
outrated he might be the underdog by 98
but he's a dangerous Knight or flare on
his tactical prowess has not waned it
has not diminished and I'm expecting
some very combative games here
Yeah a hundred percent I mean uh Vasquez
I think will do well to just make it
complicated tactical I think going into
those slow grindy positions against
Hikaru is never really gonna gonna pan
out well for anyone really but as you
see the players on screen here I mean
Hikaru is not one to shy away from that
challenge Daniel he's one of the best
tacticians in the world and uh I think I
think we might get some really wild
positions early on
yeah what makes Hikaru such a dangerous
player is that he is a chameleon he
adapts to the surroundings in this case
he adapts to his opponent and he tends
to choose precisely the kinds of
positions that his opponent doesn't like
but
I'm still hoping for a night or if I'm
hoping that Hikaru launches head first
into the types of positions that Rodrigo
Vasquez has made his career on has
staked his claim on we're gonna see one
E4 from Rodrigo Vasquez in his white
games and when Hikaru is playing white
my expectation is he's going to his
trusty Knight F3 systems trying to get
the position as quiet and as maneuvering
style as possible
right now that's a that's a good point
Hikaru is someone I think we're more
familiar with his style the positions he
likes what openings he goes for
um when it comes to Rodrigo Vasquez
definitely people won't be as familiar
but I I think as the games progress
you'll you'll start to get a feel how
these two players are going to balance
out against one another Hikaru another
thing that I think should be said is
he's such a quick player such an
intuitive player and Vasquez especially
at 52 years of age not sure how much
he's playing online lately but the
interesting thing about him is he really
is a seasoned online player this isn't
like you know a 50 year old player who's
coming in like trying to figure out how
the computer
works.com
not the case at all I can't stress that
enough this is a guy that's literally
been playing chess online since like
maybe before I even started chess or
something and before many of the viewers
before many of you watching this we're
born he was Caster on ICC and that was a
name much like Daenerys Targaryen that
breathed fi that breathed fire and fear
uh the moment that you were paired with
him the five-minute pool and here we go
seat thoughts fastened contents May
shift throughout the flight Hikaru
Nakamura has the white pieces in game
one and let's see how well my prediction
will age what will we see on move one
from the Czar of chess.com Knight F3 is
on the board
well called
um Knight F3 E3 yeah you called these
these systems that he goes for it might
involve a B3 which he loves to throw in
sometimes even as move number one it's
like he car with specialty but B3 C4 and
maybe not committing that d-pawn too
quickly and just allowing for a more
flexible setup
and G3 by Hikaru of course you can play
this system without the double fiend
keto but Hikaru has taken a a very
particular kind of fondness for the
system I think it started in the RCC he
was playing that exclusively people were
preparing for him and yet he covered
just somehow manages to get really good
positions out of the system even though
if you turn the engine on it's just
giving zeros everywhere yeah and that's
why you know it's become a more modern
way to approach the shorter time
controls especially as a higher rated
player you just approach the the game as
like well I don't need to get a crazy
opening Advantage if you're horroring
this game I just need to get a game that
hopefully isn't full of a ton of theory
that might catch me off guard and you
know the better player theoretically
should just outplay uh the opponent just
make higher quality moves over the
course of a long game now of course
that's theoretical in nature Dania it
doesn't always play out like that over
the board
yeah it doesn't and in this kind of
system both sides are sort of taking an
isolationist approach E4 it's move 12
and this is the first Contact that we
have between any of the pieces and it's
not sort of major contact because black
C5 Pawn is the most well-defended Pawn
on the board and casts are taking a very
ambitious Queen side approach shifting
his Pawn forward to B5 grabbing space
covering the C4 square of course the
downside of that move is that the C6
Pawn is weakened and we do see the move
Knight F3 to D4 played pretty frequently
in this line but Iman I think a lot of
people who see this kind of position for
the first time are very tempted to play
E5 let's go E5 let's push the Knight
back closing the center isn't always the
best prescription uh for white in these
types of positions right
yeah no you you said it exactly and if
you take a look at the bishop on H7 for
black it actually starts to get a little
more optimistic as soon as the move E5
is played so E5 actually takes your
Bishop as white on B2 and it blocks that
diagonal meanwhile opening up to the
bishop on H7 so it's double edge
definitely E5 is a is a serious
consideration and at some point white
might go for it but it's very
double-edged and it's not just like Oh
Black is losing time moving their Knight
it's very bad no it's just going to be a
different kind of double-edged struggle
and dare I say I I quite like the way
that uh I was gonna say Caster that
Vasquez
is handling the opening he's
accumulating his pieces on the queen
side he's playing very consecutively and
he's basically staying solid Hikaru
trading a pair of knights on E5 so I'm
kind of curious how Hikaru plans to
unwind in the center and on the king
side he's probably gonna continue
playing slowly he might as well throw in
the move A4 uh trying to get the queen
Side Pawn structure to kind of dry up
and maybe
I mean the dream for white of course is
uh to secure the C4 Square for the night
but black is not going to move the Deep
one in a million years never mind right
right I guess he is a million years has
passed Daniel flies when you're having
fun it really does
he takes E4 I don't know if I'm in love
with that call by Vasquez what do you
think so I was about to say like now the
question is more for Hikaru if Pawn
takes you control that D5 Square yes but
structurally it's really nice to have
the D3 C2 B3 pawns like that the bishop
on H7 is just kind of biting against
that D3 Pawn uh hopefully for the rest
of the game if you're Hikaru
um and wow what a decision I I think
Hikaru is not interested in playing D
takes E4 so much so like he's willing to
give up his Bishop
yeah after D4 you mentioned it's so
important in these positions to judge
the activity level of your Bishops and
here the bishop would once again be sort
of biting on granite so hikara prefers
to keep the position open now
interestingly Vasquez decides not to
take twice on e4 so he lets the bishop
stay alive the bishop slinks back to G2
and optically I think it looks like
White's better but Black's position is
still so incredibly solid there are no
targets there's a lot of ways to
continue activating the pieces Bishop B7
and C5 to D4 maybe the knight from F6
could jump into D5 so objectively the
position you know remains pretty
balanced
yeah I really like your Bishop C5 to D4
idea um for a few reasons first of all
Bishop takes F6 I don't think you can
fully classify that as an issue for
black
um let's say Bishop takes the Knight on
F6 Pawn takes back I know it looks weird
but same time opposite Bishops and white
doesn't really have a lot to do other
than maybe you know Queen G4 check and
queen H5 but you know what comes next
Black's Pawn gets to have five okay it's
very double edged but I think black is
actually okay with these double pawns so
that part of it I'm totally okay with
don't mind the double pawns the other
thing I always remind people is that
when you're playing against the two
Bishops the best plan and the position
almost close your eyes you can do this
every time take whatever Bishop you have
and trade it for the bishop of the same
color that'll almost always be a very
good positional plan and if black could
take the bishop on E7 and White's Bishop
on E5 take them off the board that would
be a great a great trade oh and I made
A4 as a sample move to illustrate the
bishop C5 line and it is on the board
now I mentioned this move in the context
of trying to carve out the C4 Square for
a night white no longer has any Knights
but I think the value of this move Still
Remains I mean you're putting some
pressure on Black's Queen side but yeah
with a C4 Square you know unoccupied
territory Vazquez says all right I'm
happy to close the center I'm happy to
close the queen side rather and I think
this makes the bishop C5 Bishop D4 idea
I'm on even more positionally scary for
white given how weak the C3 squares in
the long run I could consider some sort
of a knight maneuver to C3
yeah Knight D5 Bishop F6 is another
pretty natural way to trade the dark
Square Bishops
um it looks like he might be going for
something similar because if Bishop B2 I
suspect he's interested in Bishop F6 and
there's a reason why Hikaru played
Bishop F4 it's I think he's trying to
really preserve that piece
he's trying to keep his two Bishops the
position has stabilized and they're
going to maneuver for the next couple of
Moves In the meantime let's catch the
start of the other two games first and
foremost we have Jeffrey Jean against
Alexander board Nick Jeffrey has the
white pieces and do not be surprised to
see a philador defense by boardnick he
might be one of the only uh regularly
competing GMS on chess.com to play the
Philadelphia and his second opening is
the alicon so the guy doesn't care what
the cool kids play he has his own stuff
and he knows it pretty damn well
exactly yeah he's he is the cool kids
um yeah exactly he's got his setups he
he knows them so well as you said and
that's such an interesting style to have
uh where you're almost daring everyone
you're saying look this is what I do
it's fine if you know about it go ahead
and prepare for me but I'm preparing my
stuff just as well and I'm ready for you
know ready to take all Challengers
um because it really is kind of like a
theoretical dare when you're playing an
opening that isn't topped here and
you're playing it routinely your
opponents should theoretically be able
to you know drum up some sort of Engine
line or maybe find the best way to play
against it but Reddit to bordner he
doesn't care he's just playing what what
he knows
yeah he's sort of very very consistent
he's principles in his own way
and Jeffrey Zhang deploying the dark
squared Bishop to F4 as far as I
remember this is the sort of
recommendation in the most recent books
that have been written on one E4
um I think Negi uh recommended in his
you know well-known series boardnick
immediately responds with Knight C6
challenging the Knight on D4 and the one
thing you don't want to do automatically
here I'm on I think you'll co-sign this
is you don't automatically want to take
on C6 the problem with this is that it
opens the B file and this Pawn mask in
the center is actually really really
hard to deal with if you wait even
though visually Black's Pawn structure
is damaged
yeah and you know once the Rook comes to
B8 you start to feel that with that
Bishop out on F4 it's like okay that me
two Pawn's a little annoying you play B3
and the Knight on C3 is a little bit
loose so makes more sense Bishop B5 and
after Bishop D7 white has the option to
just leave things as they are or to
maybe take on C6 with the bishop instead
so you still have the flexibility of the
knight in the center
and generally Bishop F4 insinuates that
you want a castle Queen side but white
is under no obligation to follow through
on that you can very well Castle
kingside here if you prefer and another
idea that you sometimes see is an early
E5 Pawn push and if you can force black
to play D takes E5 and B take C6 then
the queen Side Pawn structure really
starts to look like an eyesore
yeah yeah and after let's say B takes C6
E5 I don't even have to make any moves
on the board of mine exactly there's the
idea you're making it for me
there it is I mean I mean of course Pawn
takes E5 but Knight D5 is the way to try
to keep the you know deep Pawn on D6 but
while we were maybe worried about
getting uh isolated C pawns after move
like Knight D5 you know Knight takes D5
Pawn takes D5 you just take on D6 and
all of a sudden yeah you've got the same
double bonds they're just over on the D
file now
this is this is a nasty situation
Whitewood castle and and it's only car
park with slay five dragons to get a
position like this so would someone like
Jose real capablanca this is the
nightmare scenario for black
vortnick for that reason
he captures on E5 and he castles and so
he is saddled with this sort of this
this weak Pawn Mass on the queen side on
the other hand the center has opened up
and just like the Hikaru game black is
the one with the bishop pair so I think
you shouldn't be fooled by the relative
sort of it it appears the black's
position is passive but with the center
being as open as it is things can change
here at the drop of a hat I'm on
yeah the pieces can get out so quickly
whether it's C5 Bishop C6 uh whether
it's Bishop G4
um you know Rook B8 Rook E8 is you're
highlighting like the pieces can really
flow into the game easily for white of
course you've got you know the two open
files in the center you want to bring
the Rooks to but the Bishops I think are
gonna do a good job pressuring this
position and I think that's why we can
see the eval bar hovering around 0.00
right now
yeah
um we are going to keep an eye on this
middle game as it unfolds and the other
game that we haven't looked at yet is of
course Fabiano caruana's duel against
Martin croftsif Fabi with the white
pieces in game one
and this looks the smacks of a Queen's
Gambit declined
and one in which white has already given
up his dark skirt Bishop Aman in all
three games right now one of the sides
has the bishop pair kind of interesting
yeah and that's uh probably the most
iconic imbalance in chess you know the
bishop pair everyone touts the bishop
pair obviously it's great to have but
it's not just like a guarantee you know
the bishop pair is not better in every
single position and that's why we've
seen
um for example here with the white
pieces Fabiano caruana he's actually
giving up his Bishop on G3 played H
takes G3 and what does he have in
instead he has a big lead in development
open H file and the option maybe to play
for E4 in the center
yeah the option to play for E4 later
down the line maybe G4 G5 using the pawn
as a battering ram especially if black
wants to Castle kingside yeah and Fabi
continues with the move Knight C3 to E2
well I wonder where he's going with that
Knight
it's a lot of possible destinations
yeah keep an eye on that night we'll
keep you updated where it ends up uh you
know the weird thing about 92 is that
let's say I take any piece Queen Bishop
and if I just give you a check on that
diagonal I'm kind of asking you okay
wait a minute how are you even blocking
this check Daniel
yeah if we pull up an analysis board
this is kind of a fascinating situation
my inclination would be to play King F1
here I think having said a you have to
say B the one thing I don't want to do
is offer a queen trade with Queen C3
walks into Bishop before maybe Queen D2
but after King F1 I think it's
you know I think white will get the
knights F4 and then you could make the
case that ultimately the king is going
to park itself on E2 and with the center
being as closed as it is
optically this looks a little bit ugly
but
I think white can probably get away with
this I'm not in love with White's
position though by any means make no
mistake yeah King F1 is not a not a
natural move but if Babi is well let's
say head on time comfortable with this
position playing Ella Tempo and he's
just gone 92. then I feel like there
yeah exactly I feel like he's
comfortable with it Dania
ah Knight F2 I love Tempo yes I mean I
think if you just say ala Tempo then
everyone has to respect whatever you
just said or on tap yeah
can you tell me what beers you have on
tap air in this establishment all right
Heineken but um
when
we are going to switch back to hikaru's
game and uh it appears come on that
Hikaru has not managed to squeeze the
most out of his bishoper they are in an
end game and it looks like the first
game is going to end in a draw
yeah it looks like it's going to end in
a draw but make no mistake it's one of
these draws where you pat yourself on
the back if you're um Rodrigo because of
course it's it's uh it's equal but I
gotta be honest I like the Knight like
if I want to take either side of this
position I'll take the Knight it's
relatively closed off Bishop doesn't
have a lot of targets
um so I think yikar will will get a draw
here but let's say the colors were
flipped for a moment Dania wouldn't you
expect Hikaru to take this position with
black and well certainly beat me with it
but push for for an advantage I was
literally opening my mouth to say that I
think I when I said the game and then in
a draw it's because playing with the
white pieces but Vasquez is kind of
making me eat my words look at that
night now I was sitting on B6 or
wherever you know deep dark corner it
was banished to and all of a sudden it's
reaching out five and guess where it can
go to from F5 it can go to D4 White's
got this terribly weak Pawn on C2 and
here's one of the problems that white is
facing if you go so let's say rookie two
Knight F5 this threatens a fork I don't
know you play Rook D2 Now The Rook is
banished to a passive Square black can
shift The Rook to E7 and potentially
prepare the move E5 so
I actually feel like if Rodrigo Vazquez
is willing to take some risk and there
isn't even that much risk that you're
taking white has no way to make progress
he's got a serious shot of winning this
game I'm on this might be the best
chance he's gonna get the entire match
exactly about to say those those exact
words
um if you don't take your chance here
then you know where do you think your
chances are gonna lie why did he take
two seconds in this position
well he's about 11 minutes right he
should be thinking about Knight D5
Knight D5 at least has to be calculated
no yeah this might win the game because
after Bishop takes D5
I think you just played easy yeah and
Brook B7 resigns because D4 is coming
you're gonna lose all of your queen side
pawns what the heck yeah that's I I
actually this would be resignation I
don't think yikar would take that night
but if you don't take the Knight I mean
the Pawn's just defended right and you
can there's still some work to be done
but uh no this looks like a a Miss by
Rodrigo and also I have to say shaky
start for Hikaru um clearly he's been
outplayed here by by his opponent he's
you know I think within more of a draw
territory now than a couple moves ago
dodged a bullet but tons of time on the
clock for Rodrigo you should play this
but I just can't get over the fact that
not to be sort of a you know armchair
General here but C3 was a blunder by
Hikaru you could see the email bar at
plus four yeah not an exaggeration
and and when an opponent plays a move
like C3 which is as committal as this
move is and you've got as much time as
Rodrigo Vasquez does
you have to you know it's incumbent on
you to spend a little bit more time
calculating the obvious move I think
there was a little bit of trust that was
happening there what do you think a
little a little bit of trust but also
it's like again if Hikaru was with the
black pieces this game would probably be
over right now like if some people would
resign this exactly uh you know if white
played C3 against Hikaru he would look
at that move and be like wait a minute
C3 that's a little bit too much you know
white swipe's trying too much here
Knight D5 and take advantage of it so it
does take some experience I think
grinding out these positions and
honestly this might be a situation where
Hikaru gets a draw because he's Hikaru
and you should be very happy with that
result here probably an opportunity
missed for uh Rodrigo obviously it draws
a great result but it's a long match and
ultimately if you're gonna you know
knock out Hikaru from the tournament you
do have to win a game whether it's an
army game or not
yeah sometimes people fall into the Trap
of you know as you said patting
themselves on the back for a draw this
is a great result especially with the
black pieces but definitely like you're
saying Hikaru has three more games the
match is still tied right it's not like
a draw is a moral Victory but it doesn't
necessarily Advance your cause in the
match all that much I think when Vasquez
is going to be looking at this game
uh maybe before the second game begins
maybe after the match he is going to be
kicking himself because they win with
the black pieces in game one that
basically puts Hikaru the cars back
against the wall right away Iman for
sure
um so I think it's appropriate to be
critical here Dania because this is a
knockout tournament and I think you know
one of the favorites to maybe win the
entire thing is not going to give you an
opportunity with the black pieces to you
know convert that type of Advantage uh
too often like that's going to be few
and far between so uh good result there
but could have been more
um I wonder if he's gonna be thinking
about that in the oncoming games as we
switch over to the game which is still
in progress and is still very balanced
here between Bortnick and Jeffrey and I
think we see just in the kind of end
game that they have gotten the extent to
which wardnick understands these
philador positions
essentially knows the only sign that his
Queen Side Pawn structure at one point
was totally ruined is the fact that A7
is isolated but then the E3 Pawn is
isolated we have a bishop against the
Knight situation
I agree I think the position is totally
balanced here I would say probably a 75
percent or higher chance of a draw here
one of those situations where like I
don't know exactly the way that this
endgame is going to go but I get the
sense that it's going to remain balanced
unless one of the sides blunders
yeah yeah
um I'm trying to think like you know
white definitely has an idea of maybe
King F2 let's just say Knight E4 happens
and white trades the knights right then
I think white can start to get a little
optimistic about playing Knight versus
Bishop
um because I think I think the Knight
always has a good chance to to outplay
the bishop in in those cases but other
than that it's tough to find real
imbalances here Dania and I agree 100 I
think we're headed for a draw on this
one as well
yeah yeah but you you made an instructor
point there before we switched the Fabi
game okay white plays H3 so he takes the
game in a different direction but
White's biggest hope here is to use the
knights as uh you know weapons to attack
this queen side so for example if we
pull up an analysis board here just to
show how this could possibly go wrong
for black let's say the bishop drops
back to F5 the Knight moves into D4
attacking C6 attacking F5 forcing the
bishop back then maybe you play the move
B4 in order to uh prevent C5 and fix the
weakness on C6 eventually later down the
line you can play Knight A4 Knight C5 so
it's what I'm not trying to suggest that
is that the game is over and that there
is no hope for either side if I would
have to choose a side I would probably
still take white but just by a little
smidge yeah yeah and actually Jeffrey
has gone for something a little bit
different which is
um encouraged the bishop to trade with a
knight on F3 with H3 so he's kind of
provoked it and then we saw this move d4
taking advantage of the pin on the E
file by fortnite and I think this should
just be good liquidation as now you see
that look that Grand Master look right
up to the ceiling it's like wait where
are the answers to my current dilemma
which is you know if Knight takes Pawn
what do you make of that end game
imagine all the pieces disappeared I
hate those situations or you have to
evaluate some sort of amorphous Pawn end
game where both sides of Pawn majority
is on either flank and you know all
three results are possible the fact of
the matter is that in this spawn end
game The Rules of Engagement are
different when you have two pawns that
are one file away from each other I'm on
a rook end game these are weaknesses in
a pod end game this is often the best
arrangement you could ask for because it
makes it as difficult as possible for
black to create a past Pawn black is the
same thing on the queen side it's
anybody's game yeah and I think there's
a reason that the eval bar is always
going to hang out around yeah the center
of the board here but make no mistake
it's so easy to lose the king and pawn 9
game one wrong move the engine about
seen it the whole way through right
they're not concerned at all but
um I I think that this could be lost by
either player honestly they're not good
yeah and I just made a sample of H5
totally natural let's start pushing the
pawns Apparently after B4 White's
already winning it's plus five so it's
really as easy as that to lose an end
game like this and I think for that
reason we're thinking it's game one you
really don't want to lose and he decides
to keep the pieces on the board I think
that's a prudent call I think that
greatly increases the probability that
this game ends in uh relatively
uneventful drop okay we'll leave group
players to contest this complex but
ultimately balanced end game and we will
check out our final game
Aviano caruana has just a little bit of
a Time Advantage here
's a bit of a Time Advantage one thing
you could say about the position I'm a
little focused on these triple pawns
um you know it's not too often in chess
that you see first of all triple pawns
but I gotta be honest tripled pawns
where there's also still a supporting
Pawn so not right not isolated pawns
because when you think of how you get
Triple pawns it would be the two pawns
on either side joining the same file so
then it means you've had even another
exchange to bring upon closer that's
pretty rare yeah the pawn I guess from
how did the pawn get to F4 well the pawn
from G2 went to F3 oh the pawn from H2
went to G3 as you're saying exactly that
is that is actually rare you know
collectors of rare chess situations
should open their catalog and put
another entry in but speaking of putting
an entry in Fabiana car wanna make about
to make an entry into H7 with his Queen
and there's no way the black can stop
him and if you play Queen G6 you drop a
pawn in the end game despite these
triple pawns white can still ultimately
use these pawns them on in order to
crash through on the king side with an
eventual g425 black situation is pretty
dire here
yeah you want to have that night already
on the f8 Square you know Knight on f8
and there is no bait that's not the case
and so there's only one option Daniel
you can't just give up material you
gotta run
you gotta run with your own two legs and
that is exactly what craft stuff does
now the big question will Fabiano still
infiltrate H7 there's our answer now the
threat here is rookie one and that will
set up essentially Unstoppable mate on
h8 how does craftive deal with that
yeah because if you go uh Queen F6
rookie one
96 there's this like F5 idea right you
want to kick the Knight
let's pull up an analysis board here
this is interesting if rookie one what
you're saying is 96 loses to F5 and if
you move your knight you get checkmated
on h8 because E7 is protected so I guess
after rookie won the only move seems to
be Rook takes C1 sounds totally
counter-intuitive why give up the e-file
but now black has this defensive
resource for G5 and somehow the balance
is kept by this queen which is a hero
amazing whoa It's On The Board
he's found it everything that we just
said is on the board honestly G5 is is a
total shock move because you know you
can see fabby's face is kind of leaning
in and he's he knows that he's
definitely missed something there and
with time ticking down that's a head
shake from Fabiano and an opportunity
for Martin Kravitz to get back in this
game
and you can see the consternation the
the frustration there for Fabi maybe he
only saw G6 which is you know 99 of
cases the way that you do this but this
drops the H6 spawn and hear what is more
than chilling
but after G5 the Knight is coming into
E6 let's not forget I'm on that the D4
Pawn is a huge Target so if black can
repel the attack we could be talking
about black taking over the initiative
pretty darn soon I I'm gonna go ahead
and put myself out there and say we are
talking about that Daniel I think we're
already there
um Fabi is definitely in like kind of
recovery mode
um yes you can take on G5 but it doesn't
appear that there's a way to make
progress because the queen on F6 covers
everything H6 h8 there are no checks
that white can use so it's like yeah
you've gotten into H7 but where are you
going next
um and you're calling it whether it's
rookie eight by Black Knight 96 I mean
just liquidate the pieces and White's
pawns are going to start falling apart
and the other thing that is that if
white would have played F5 the Knight
can actually access D4 through B5 you
can fly through London Heathrow as well
as Frankfurt so Bobby I think he's
recovered well he plays the move Rook H1
he still has that six minute time
Advantage so if you can keep the Queens
on the board if you can keep the
position relatively complex I think that
the clock might might play a role here
we'll see
absolutely
um Rook H1 feels like a nice move to
keep things going the interesting thing
is that
let's say the d-pawn falls and the H
Pawn Falls black wouldn't be too upset
about that as long as you can maybe
trade the Queens
um so if you play something like I don't
know Knight
96 let's say
um Rook takes H6 and queen G7 then I
think what's maybe interesting is this
move Queen h8 which it's not on
everyone's radar because you think Queen
G7 okay he's kind of got it covered
Queen h8 you definitely can't take it
without losing your rook and then yeah
you fall victim this beautiful
but not Queen takes A8 because then
black recap exactly exactly there's
still a lot of potential to blunder is
what you're saying and if you try to
beat white to the punch with the move
Queen G7 well it still doesn't entirely
solve all of the problems maybe this is
the best way uh to effectuate the queen
trade but if you just blindly take on H7
you just end up losing a bunch of Pawns
here
um and you know Bishop G6 becomes a
problem so craftive now with one minute
on the clock I think one thing a month
that's not talked about enough is the
way the top layers recover from blunders
right they almost never when they
blunder a lot of players just
immediately collapse top layers just
immediately find a good follow-up move
which I think is exactly what Fabi has
managed to do but craftive he stays
sharp and he keeps the Knight on C7 so
that it protects the Rook on A8 taking
the sting out of Queen h8 check
yeah that's a that's a huge detail Rook
takes H6 now black can just move the
queen maybe to G7 again and queen h8
you're happy to trade the Queens play
King G7 King E7
um and the funny thing about that pawn
on F4 that is black you don't care white
can have that pawn in any end game it's
like okay you want tripled isolated
pawns notice how the Knight against the
bishop in any end game can just go to E6
and there's another thing that white can
do to stop the knight from taking every
single Pawn on dark Square yeah that's
like Pac-Man except there's no bad guy
because the pawns aren't a dark Square
no this is a this is concerning for
Fabian I love the fact that crafts have
actually took a minute to play G takes
F4 he didn't Panic he realized that
finding the correct move in this
position is a lot more important than
preserving x amount of time
so yeah it is a three result game I
think if Fabi wins this it will be
because of the clock
but can he find a way to keep some meat
on the bone here to keep the Queens on
the board and to keep the position
complicated I don't see anything off the
top of my head
and the weirdest part is that after Rook
takes H6 it's a force Queen trade after
Q7 it's not just like oh Black's trying
to trade the Queens it's yeah the Queens
are coming off the board now that's
exactly what black wants it's crazy and
just to reiterate Queen ha check which
previously ended up winning the Rogue
here yeah the knight's gonna move into
A8 it's a bad night but it's only gonna
take it two moves to move back to the
promised land either through B5 or
through E6 and once the D4 Pawn is lost
once it's sacked black will have a four
on two on the king side this could just
end up being totally lost for white
and if you uh if you want to even
continue from from this position and I
like I would love to just put
um you know takes on on f4 on the board
uh Knight C7 King D2 96 King E3 and
let's just play a move like A5 for black
uh Bishop F5 King F6 and Bishop takes
Knight and you just get this really
sweet visual of a king and pawn end game
where I think this is like the reminder
of why uh isolate double isolated or now
triple isolated pawns absolutely are
terrible
um and you can probably show just how
white is going to be zugswang here and
they're gonna lose every single Pawn for
succession
Bobby after a hefty think there does end
up playing Rook takes H6 okay now
crafter has to play Queen G7 he's got to
do it quickly to be honest I'm not even
thinking about playing Queen takes D4
here I am not tempting fate and neither
does the Ukrainian Grand Master he has
managed to steer the game into an end
game he's better he's fine
yeah and better is is a a term that I
don't think Martin would use for his
position if the queens were on the board
yeah maybe he's up a pawn or maybe he's
doing well but with the Queens there and
the time low you start to get a little
shaky but knowing a hundred percent that
those Queens are disappearing from the
board right now you really start to
become comfortable get optimistic and
remind yourself that hey I haven't got
an advantage and I'm I'm not at risk of
getting mated or there's not committing
big tactics the only thing that might
happen is just me failing to convert at
this point
yeah I think that's a good way of
putting it well the situation has more
or less stabilized we can take this
opportunity to quickly update you on our
other remaining game between Jeffrey and
Bortnick now earlier on this end game
board Nick offered a draw which Jeffrey
Jean declined is he regretting that
right about now he's still down upon
and I feel like he's got compensation in
the form of Black's weak Queen side
pawns but it could evaporate if black
consolidates his thesis
so you're saying he there was a draw
offer
Bortnick offered a draw and Jeffrey
declined it a little bit earlier
very interesting yeah because I mean the
uh The Rook obviously for black is a
little bit suspiciously placed the
Knight on E3 you can see does this
beautiful job along with the pawn on F4
it just takes every single Square D5 F5
E5 D5 so the uh The Rook on H5 doesn't
have a lot of squares and I believe that
that's why the the efal bar is like
anywhere close to 0.00 otherwise you
know this has been a tremendous
achievement for uh Bortnick in this game
so far like
um if he could get something like Knight
to D5 right and you'd like maybe trade
those Knights off the board definitely
start to get optimistic about a uh an
end game up a pawn
yeah it seems that Knight D5 is is the
safe option and it is only by the skin
of his teeth it is only on the strength
of the fact that the two on three is
basically a dead draw again I mentioned
that in the pawn end game this Pawn
Arrangement is ideal in The Rook end
game it is as well because again it
prevents the side of the pawn majority
from easily creating a passer here black
can play A5 and according to the engine
white doesn't even have to play Rook A6
here which would lead uh potentially to
a two on three which Jeffrey should
still be able to draw it appears that
white can just bite his time with King
G4 and the bottom line is that the Rook
is tied down to D5 it can never move
away and if it does move away white
takes on C5 simultaneously defending C2
so it's kind of a positional draw just
because black can make no progress wow
interesting yeah that's uh you know it
looks like Knight D5 or trade those
tricky Knights off get the get the end
game like it's hard not to play that
move because your Rook is so trapped on
H5 but if you're Bortnick I mean this is
a great success not I mean you you had a
tremendous opening success I think no
danger at all and I mean look at this
you're drawing and maybe even pushing if
Jeffrey misplays yeah Jeffrey's got 90
seconds and when you're in time pressure
this approach of just not doing anything
just by definition doing nothing is
difficult and making the determination
that your opponent has no way to make
progress it's a lot easier said than
done so I think if you get a two on
three Bortnick just has ways I think
we've talked about this before boardnik
is an absolute magician when it comes to
pulling out drawn end games like he has
basically won Rook vs Rook on the board
he's like the most interesting man in
the world he has won The Rook versus
Rook end game many times but over the
board rather than on the clock you know
yep no exactly
um
players yeah
uh credit to both players honestly
finding what I think is the correct line
uh but this is the moment right this is
what is going to tell us whether or not
Jeffrey understands that he should do
nothing
for some reason I'm having some sort of
deja vu I feel like I've seen this game
before it happened and I feel like
Jeffrey's about to blunder something but
man Jeffrey is such a great defender
here he's got 34 seconds but that two
second increment is absolutely vital in
situations like this he's gone Rook A6
though yeah Rook D2 C4 might be the
intention
oh and maybe boarding himself should go
C4 right with the idea of playing PC
Rook C5 and just chomping on the
remaining C Pawns
yep I mean at least you're giving
yourself a chance here with the black
pieces to to actually enjoy that extra
pawn it is gonna be a draw uh two
against three on the king side but
anything can happen as you said time
getting low and at least give yourself a
chance
yeah I've seen the the uh
prevailing side actually win or the side
of the extra Pawn Win these types of two
on three end games
a lot especially when one side has let's
say 10 seconds you're playing on
increment you've got to make judgment
calls really really quickly just that's
exactly what I was saying Bortnick knows
how to put his opponent in a situation
where he has to make some sort of a
decision and he's got to do it quickly
15 seconds now for Jeffrey Zhang and
this is a case in point him on the Rook
is getting to A3 and now the King on H4
is a little bit precarious because now
the C Pawn if it falls that four Pawn
Falls with check right so there's just
some things down the line that you don't
always foresee
I think it might be time for Rook A3 the
King has entered a path of no return it
can't drop back to G3 because then
you'll end up giving the B3 Pawn away
with check as well so I think there
might be something weird that happens
where the black Rook gets to B3 and the
white king is in this weird spot so
black might play Pawn H5 if King G4 then
the king's stuck on H4 and later black
might play Rook F3 to go win that F4
Pawn by force so this actually is
starting to look very suspicious for
what there's some checkmating ideas that
are also not entirely out of the
question by the way Fabiano caronus game
is also entering the time scramble phase
I don't know which game to turn to as
Bortnick Ponders his next move okay
let's quickly check into the Fabiano
caruana game yeah it's just it's the
best situation to have we have two
fascinating games Martin craftev
continues to push this end game
Advantage now Fabby himself is down to
30 seconds yeah and I don't I don't know
how it got into so much chaos here but
this is incredibly interesting with
Knight E4 coming and then D3 is gonna be
a killer move
oh it is because Bishop takes D3 loses
the bishop to Rook D2 great spot by you
fabi's pawns are so far backhamon
they're way too far back but he walked
into it yeah now you gotta play like
King E1 or something but I mean you have
three yeah you can just dislodge this
bishop and Fabi is at serious risk of
losing this game this has been a game of
doubled and tripled pawns and again much
like White's triple pawns earlier the
double pawns are a strength because if
the bishop gives itself up for one of
them you're gonna have the other one to
promote here comes the king Knight D2 if
Rook B3 oh or Knight C5 or Knight C5
sorry yeah it's over
D3 is coming amazing he has to take but
this is I mean dead on the spot Pawn
takes D3 and Fabi knows it's it's over
D2 or Rook F1 and D2
it's all over
wow what a result
um unbelievable I mean the way that he
stayed in there as uh as as that game
finishes uh we jump back to our live
game here but Danny is still reeling at
the end of that is uh it's gonna be
Fabiano and are we gonna see the same
thing over here
Jeffrey's resigned vortic has managed to
Win It fist pump at the end that means a
lot to him especially we were looking at
that eval bar 0.00 the engine was
screaming but you and I weren't
convinced trying to remind everybody
that no time plays a factor and you
mentioned it who is one of the absolute
best at squeezing something from nothing
all excited and you called it he won the
F4 upon he got Jeffrey's King boxed in
and as we look at the results from round
one what an eventful start to today's
action a draw by Rodrigo Vasquez Fabiano
caruana loses his first White game
against crafts if and Alexander Bortnick
also wins of the black pieces so upsets
all around wow this bodes well for the
rest of the action we've got some
comebacks to see and Hikaru Nakamura he
was worse basically the entire game so
he's gonna have to step up his game as
well we're gonna have to step up our
coffee game because we're gonna go on a
very short break ladies and gentlemen uh
and when we come back we are going to
get the second game of this amazing day
of action here at the chess.com Global
Championship stay tuned
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the 2022-23 Collegiate chess league in
partnership with the Nace star league
begins Saturday September 24th sign ups
close on Saturday for the 24th for
students
make sure to sign up at go.chess.com CCL
to represent your school in the Premier
chess league for college students don't
forget the Collegiate chess League
coming your way very soon
well what else is coming your way very
soon game two of the cgc here with
Grandmaster Roman Hamilton Amman we had
surprises all around in game one
yeah we we absolutely did Dania and I
think going into this look the uh the
Americans were all favorites uh coming
in but what we saw was great positions
and then slowly getting outplayed by
their opponents we saw Martin kravisiv
take a tough position where Fabiano was
honestly dominating from the opening he
was down on time everything looked tough
for him but he recovered got a queen
trade and ultimately didn't just
equalize after that he took it home for
the full point against Fabiano and now
the Americans on the back foot Hikaru I
think happy to escape with a draw could
have been a loss in his first game and
Bortnick squeezing you know water from
Stone and coming with the win as well so
we've seen upsets uh to start things off
on every board very excited for game two
yeah me too I mean there's nothing worse
in a cgc match than losing game one
mentioned on a previous broadcast that
it's easy to fall into the Trap of
assuming that I've got four games I got
three more games to come back with most
of these players almost never lose their
lose with white so in game two you
basically have to win we haven't had any
players surrounding a 2-0 uh deficit yet
so for Fabiano caruan and Jeffrey Zhang
it is Mission critical to at the very
least stabilize the situation with the
draw
yep no you said it best
um I think that in hikaru's case things
are not as uh as dire let's say as the
other matches of course uh the other
players on the back foot it means that
they are now required to win to get back
into this match but
um I think we were critical of Rodrigo's
we see the game on our screen now
getting into game number two we were
critical that he didn't push for more
Dania because that opportunity against a
guy as good as Hikaru is not gonna
happen too often so very curious to see
how Rodrigo bounces back with the white
pieces now is he looking to push or do
you think he's just you know interested
in maybe stabilizing this match
I mean it's it's hard to say I think the
question depends on whether uh Rodrigo
reviewed that game during the break I
think if he's good and he discovered
that he could play beats xc3 he's gonna
be angry during these matches ignorance
generally is bliss if he didn't review
it and he might be pretty happy with his
result and maybe then he'll play a
little bit more solidly
now what surprises me is his opening
choice you would almost think that
Hikaru is playing white here because
he's channeling a type of Hikaru opening
he's played one D4 and he's taking the
game into very sort of uh Placid
positional channels
yep I was gonna say takes takes and
actually D5 is sort of the theory
um for black to play so Pawn to D5 but
Hikaru likely just doesn't want to tread
into those Waters and the reason why D6
Nike car was played is not actually one
of the you know top tier moves is
because of exactly what Rodrigo played
D5 I have played this position so many
times just in quick chess Blitz or
bullet as black and you can really get a
good game I think if white does not
punish so if white just slowly plays B3
H3 rookie one Queen E2 just whatever
moves I think black gets a great game
together but what has happened to me so
many times Dania is this quick execution
I'm talking about Knight H4 F4 uh
immediately sinking pieces into the F5
Square
um and I think if you go for the throat
in this kind of game it works out really
well
and I think that's exactly what Rodrigo
Vazquez is doing he's gone not Knight H4
but Knight G5 so I think the idea is
twofolds the main concept here is f2f4
getting rid of the linchpin in Black
structure the E5 Pawn but the secondary
idea is to meet the move H6 with Knight
G to E4 and just have a nice whichever
piece ends up on e4 whether it's a nice
Knight or a bishop
uh if you can remove this knight from F6
you also get the possibility of dragging
a queen to H5 and in the event the black
Castle's King side that could get really
scary really really quickly and so
Hikaru making sure to uh stabilize the
not enough six But Here Comes F4
yep F4 happens now Black's Knight on D7
is is ready right it's gonna jump into
E5 it wants to capture back
um if that if that happens but it's all
about open lines for the white pieces
White's not thinking positionally oh
black gets the great E5 Outpost no none
of that matters it's it's about going
for the the king going for the throat
and if if Hikaru castles King side
there's gonna be something happening on
either F7 or H7
yeah this is unpleasant I mean the email
bar is showing plus one but I think we
can see why it's not one of those
mysterious plus ones
um the bishop on B7 is also not helping
Black's cause I mean it's nowhere near
being active B5 is not in the cards at
the present moment
Rodrigo Vasquez is he's adopting the
exact style that you need to adopt to
score a historic upset right he is not
holding any punches and he is taking it
to Hikaru with both colors in the
opening
he has I think he's playing in his style
uh great style tough for Hikaru to me
because I think ikaro played D6
early on here and was kind of thinking
to himself okay I'm not going to play
the main stuff D5 very explored
territory I'm gonna play this slightly
worse system and if my opponent doesn't
know like you know Surefire and how to
punish it I might get a great game but
you yeah it always feels like you're
rolling the dice a little bit because if
they do know
then suddenly you're what you're in
Hikaru situation right now where you're
down on the clock and you're kind of on
the back foot which is not a pleasant
place to be
it is not and the Knight is choosing
which place it wants to be you've got
Knight F3 which would pressure black to
take on F4 which generally is in White's
favor but I think the initial idea was
to drag this Knight back to E4 Vasquez
choose this Knight F3 I was gonna say I
actually prefer Knight E4 I can't
exactly put my finger on why I feel like
it's a little bit more zesty it's a
little bit more active
but Knight F3 by Vasquez and it seems to
me that Hikaru is not actually forced to
take on F4 I think he he's likely to
Castle here
one of the reasons why I like Knight E4
was and now that the move H6 has been
played I think black is not incentivized
to play the move G6 now the H6 Pawn will
be weak
um and G6 is also just a more tender
Square now so I wanted Knight E4 to
maybe slide back to G3 for Knight H5 or
Knight F5 and from F3 I think okay maybe
Knight H4 to F5 is still an idea but I
think it's a it's a little more solid to
have played your knight to G3 because
it's just a 30 year square Knight H4 can
be a bit loose with the bishop on E7
I agree with you I'm not the biggest fan
of how Vazquez is handling this early
middle game now I feel like rookie 8
would set up an x-ray against the queen
but no question that uh Rodrigo Vasquez
has I mean the opening has been an
unabashed success for him in the
meantime the other two games have begun
so let's check into the first moves of
Alexander Bortnick against Jeffrey Zhang
you've got an ante Berlin here that's
transposed now into a Four Knights
variation
well Jeffrey he's gonna be I think he's
gonna try to equalize the score in this
game I don't think Jeffrey's the kind of
guy who's gonna try to play solidly and
then you know try to win with white in
the next game I think he's going to try
to equalize It Here and Now
so not not in the uh the Russian School
of Chess right what is it that I always
make a draw after a loss
Berlin by by Jeffrey but I think he knew
that Alexander board Nick is not just
gonna surrender the white pieces with a
Berlin draw right right
um so actually what we see here in
support him point out that the winds all
the games in the last round were
actually The Underdogs with the black
pieces so all those great results we saw
that's what the black piece is it might
not make the biggest difference but
believe me at the highest level uh the
white pieces versus the black pieces in
terms of playing for the for a win if
you need on demand it does matter
oh it matters tremendously
and uh it's interesting actually that
Bortnick did have the possibility of
taking a Berlin draw here decided not to
a pretty bold call I think he Bortnick
from his perspective wants to win a
second game and basically finish this
match right now
is that what you like uh Danny is that
your style or would you be more of a
okay you know up one point take my
Berlin draw kind of guy I with white I
would probably take the Berlin draw with
black I probably wouldn't play the
Berlin to begin with I'd be too afraid
of my opponent because it would give me
a lot of anxiety to know that I had
essentially given up one more game and I
had not even attempted uh to quash the
deficit so anyways we're past that
boardnik decides to Castle kingside and
it's not every day that you see white
putting a knight on C3 in the rui Lopez
so this gives the position a slightly
more unconventional slightly more
traditional four nights kind of flavor
right
yeah the interesting thing about this is
you know Bishop G5 Knight D5
I don't know about you Dania but that's
uh that's my go-to and I was a kid oh
yeah used to win so many games whether
it was the Italian real Lopez doesn't
matter
um
I guess the flexibility for black here
is the d-pawn right hasn't committed
itself to D6 yet and sometimes when
white plays Bishop G5 black can even in
some cases go back to E7
um depending on what white wants to do
and we will see rookie 8 to watch over
that E5 Pawn which I feel like some
players always forget to do that they're
like oh yeah this is the real Lopez I
can just hang my e-pawn for 20 moves
yeah at some points
he's gonna take on E5 on the previous
move it should be pointed out that if
white did this here there's the classic
the classic idea Queen D4 fork in the
night in the bishop uh White actually
can save the piece here with Bishop E3
and D4 but nonetheless black solves all
of the opening problems so anyways the
position has stabilized or only six
moves in let us check in on the other
game which is craftive against caruana
and here Martin crafts of deviating from
his usual E4 so we see Vasquez playing
an uncharacteristic D4 and Martin
craftiff playing one night F3 also kind
of trying to steer the game into
relatively non-theoretical Waters
although that doesn't really exist
anymore I'm on every the waters are all
theoretical everywhere yeah exactly have
you seen the waters lately they're only
totally theoretical
I have
I wonder if there's nothing B4 in this
position that's the first move that
really jumps at me because uh okay if
the Knight was already on C6 you played
A3 to go before the ba5 right in your
face but uh here it feels like we have
this moment to do before and maybe
bishop B2 and that that d-pawn feels a
little difficult to defend so I kind of
like D4 what do you think
yeah it always feels like a huge win
when you get to play because normally
you have to you know perform the 12
labors of Hercules in order to get B4
and these benoni positions when you get
to play this move you know all on your
own you're like what's the Trap Is there
an ambush waiting for me exactly I'm
definitely playing P4 here and guess
what I think black is worse I'm very
puzzled that Fabiana has allowed this
that easily it just seems dejected I
don't know I don't want to read too much
into the body language but he seems
frustrated
and I think craft stuff needs to try to
step on the gas pedal here this is a big
chance for him uh to get a big Advantage
out of the opening and exploit perhaps a
little bit of tilt from Fabi yeah he he
didn't just lose a game last round let's
remember he he lost that position that
he was much better at and I think that
always fits differently it doesn't
matter how strong you are that will
always cause you to it'll stay in your
mind so you're playing this game you're
thinking about man if I just done this
differently like oh it was so winning
for me
um and when those thoughts enter your
mind you lose your objectivity and uh I
love the move B4 yeah is is going for it
um I think he's got as you said great
chances to really stick it to Fabiano
before Bobby maybe makes a draw or gets
comfortable and gets his white pieces
again
yeah and before we switch once again to
the Hikaru Nakamura game we've got a
couple of updates there
should be pointed out that if black
plays A5 white goes B5 and normally the
Black Knight is able to entrench itself
on the C5 square but I think given
lack's lack of development here and the
weakness of D4 and the fact that white
can play Bishop A3 to stop Knight C5
right this isn't as effective as it
normally is white is going to be I mean
look at the Evo bar look at Black's
pieces they're stuck in molasses he's in
some trouble here in the opening we'll
keep an eye on his attempts to get
himself out of the woods but speaking of
getting out of the woods Mr Nakamura
with another trick here to get himself
out of what was
a really really difficult position but
Vasquez has just wandered upon
wow and and the game progressed I would
say quite well for Rodrigo I was
actually thinking when we left it that
okay maybe he kind of let it slip away a
bit but
um wow he plays what he takes and Hikaru
is that the same face as you
takes C5 what he thought he had Bishop
B6 that's all I got
he thought he had Bishop B6 but here
after Bishop B6 let's pull up an
analysis board here to try to figure out
what it is that Vasquez has in mind
because here after Queen takes E4 Fork I
don't care Queen E7 defends the bishop
easily why why he takes D5 because I'm
on let's be real yeah you gave up the D5
Pawn it's not the end of the world he
could have gone Queen D2
forced to not force the Knight back and
then recaptured the pawn on D6 using
this typical Bishop takes G7 tactic and
hey White's not as better as he was
previously but why it's not worse I mean
white shouldn't lose this game no
Vasquez is you know collapsing here for
for absolutely no reason and now I think
the move Bishop C7 would dislodge the
Knight on D4 and cause major problems to
White's King
yeah I wouldn't say this is completely
over but you know Carl had that facial
expression as soon as C takes D5 was
played it's like you know he's ready to
pounce
right as soon as you give one of these
strong players just even an ounce just
like a little bit uh to bite on all of a
sudden you know he cars look at him he's
calculating everything he's trying to
figure out he knows he's a little bit
better here and if you're not gonna get
an advantage in every game you play so
when you do spot something a chance an
opportunity look he's got eight and a
half minutes he's gonna he's gonna have
a think here and try to figure something
out with his Bishop
yeah you can see he's leaning into the
camera he is intently he noticed he
understands the importance of this
moment he's better for the first time in
this match in this entire match in the
first two games and Hikaru always he
always delivers in these situations and
the reason Bishop C7 is so inconvenient
for white Amman is that if you simply
drop the Knight back to see uh for I
think there's this really pretty idea
Queen D1 check King F2 and now wow
Bishop H2 that's Bishop G1 is completely
Unstoppable you're gonna win something
on this diagonal it might be the queen
might be the bishop but you're not
getting both the queen and the bishop
off of the g1a7 diagonal in time and the
king is because the king is no moves
that's that's gorgeous Daniel uh Bishop
is so visual
look at this and no checks the pawn on
B6 perfectly placed the king perfectly
placed covering E7
my lions and queen F4 by Vasquez I think
the best that he can do actually
right
Hikaru looked like he when he played
Bishop C7 I mean he probably saw the
bishop H2 stuff in about five seconds
um yeah you know and then Queen F4 it
looks like he was ready for so he
anticipated this queen G6 played
guarding Checkmate unless I forget that
was a mate one threat on F7
um and now Bishop E5 and you're you're
highlighting the tactics here White's
got pressure on F7 Black's got pressure
on the G file Bishop takes H3 is in the
air
so the line that needs to be calculated
first and foremost before we look at
that I will point out that F6 I think is
not that scary for white and I think
it's due to the move Knight C4 again
exploiting the pin so after Bishop H3 I
think white was able to play Queen F7
and maybe hold the draw and this anybody
Caro he does play the move F6 so scratch
that let's get back to the game
I think Knight C4 might allow white to
solve his problems and emerge from this
game unscathed
and I guess like yeah the thing is it's
uh the move F6 you're just gonna lose
the game unless you find Knight C4 maybe
you can play Knight F7 I don't know
weird that is but point is like you're
kind of you're kind of forcing your
opponent to find a good move Knight F7
that's a hilarious move I think actually
the only reason that you want the Knight
on C4 is that after Bishop takes H3 you
have this move Bishop D6 check and then
you actually need the services of your
knight you need the division of labor
the queen defends the bishop Knight
defends the pawn and I think this far
Advanced passer is what gives white
sufficient compensation for the pawn
that's incredible honestly like first of
all I would play Knight C4 after F6 but
it wouldn't do it because I necessarily
saw all this it's just the Moon is just
the move that has to be played so this
just all works out is probably going to
be honestly for lack of a better we're
frustrating for Hikaru I think if he
sort of notices that this
line works out for Rodrigo he might
think that he's near winning after F6
yeah and
you know for vazquez's sake you hope
that he isn't under the impression that
he has blundered terribly because if you
fall into that trap especially against
Hikaru that could actually impact your
ability to successfully find defensive
options if you think the game is over
then you know you're not looking as
resiliently at the stuff that you could
do but it's amazing how resilient
White's remaining pieces are they're
able to defend everything in the center
and take the sting out of Bishop takes
H3 so will Rodrigo Vasquez find the only
move here Knight C4 I don't see a single
other thing that he could do you could
you could either clean G3 of course
Queen B1 is the answer but Queen G3 is
the only other construction that comes
to mind but credit to Rodrigo he spent
his time spent it wisely found Knight C4
a necessary only move and you know it's
kind of uh you know passing the ball
back to hikaru's side of the Court
saying okay now I found a tough move
what what comes next Bishop H3 you
pointed out is Bishop D6 move is going
to to be really really key
by the way I will interrupt the coverage
for a second to say that we are aware
that there is more unfolding drama
there's a game between Carlson and
Neiman that apparently Carlson just
resigned in two moves but uh this is
hs.com global Championship broadcast
there's also a broadcast that you're
welcome to watch on the other tournament
so we are going to stay focused on these
games you're obviously welcome to choose
the games that you watch but you know
we're commentating this tournament and
we've got plenty of action to go around
them on so we're gonna stay focused on
this because this ikara match this
Fabiana carwana match could really come
down to the wire Bishop D6 is on the
board all credit to Vasquez for finding
these three or four key defensive moves
yep and I think every match that we've
been privy to thus far has been
tremendously exciting not only just in
the first round but the fact that the
favorites find themselves behind and
this was what I was alluding to earlier
I feel like Hikaru might see the move
Knight E3 and just get this look of like
I can't believe this works like what
like how what
um
he's on the other side of such
constructions you know and you're like
I'm finally beating him I finally have
him nailed down and somehow he gets out
of it
yeah this is amazing how the night and
yeah he's starting to get that feeling I
have the same one I can't believe that
this Knight went to like D6 C4 E3 and
suddenly it's just being held together
here miraculous yeah to be honest with
you after Vazquez took on D6 I just got
the sense that hikara was gonna win in
three moves yeah but he's managed to
maintain his composure and maybe that
wealth the decades-long wealth of
experience is helping Vasquez out here
he's not really a tilter he stayed
composed and he was able to find moves
on demand Hikaru of course is still
going to be playing for a win he's going
to be taking risks here
but after Bishop C7 which has just been
played instantly the d-pawn is ready to
rumble it's a three result game I was
gonna say after D6 here like how much do
you want to play for every result Daniel
because that Bishop could end up on F A
whoa whoa whoa whoa there's G4 here
wow oh my land
that's an incredible move
D7 is threatened the bishop is trapped
black has to chooses poison if you stop
the d-pawn you lose the bishop
that's unbelievable
oh my God and he doesn't find it he
plays Bishop takes B6 so logical Bishop
D6 oh look how quickly Cara dropped his
Bishop away from H3 I'm getting yeah
he's out of there I'm not risking that
for another second B4 but look the thing
is no matter what happens with the
position doesn't white just play Maybe
A5 Bishop C5 and blacks Bishop from f8
doesn't really see the light of day
again
this is the light of the D6 spawn but I
agree
no it's such positions are almost
impossible to evaluate I think the
problem that white might encounter is if
black Parks the queen on D3 the pawn is
never really going to get to D7 so I'm
not totally seeing how White's gonna
make progress here
and I feel like if one of the sides ends
up making a blunder
the probability that white blunders is
greater and it's not just because you
know hikar has got the black pieces
although that's part of it I'll admit
yeah but that's always part of it right
you know when you're playing a guy like
a Hikaru there's a sort of a stigma that
that he carries around with him and you
know the the best players definitely put
more pressure on their opponents just by
Nature yeah you feel like every move
you're making is a blunder even if
you're like recapturing a queen
yeah you you're nodding your head this
is one of the most relatable feelings
that all Grandmasters share that of just
facing kikaru Nakamura period
yep
exactly
so this looks like a great achievement
for Vasquez after that Knight takes D5
incident I'll call it earlier I think
his recovery has been tremendous and
look at the position he's got on the
board yes he's facing the two Bishops
but he's put himself in a position uh
and he's totally equalized this game
again
yeah he has and Hikaru now is down on
the clock he's below four minutes and
that could potentially play a role as he
delivers the check on B1 let's take a
quick detour and look at the other games
we will catch the end of this game worry
not but you have a pretty crazy
development in the Portland game where
only 15 Moves In White is completely
lost in this position what the heck
happened to Alexander's position
yeah it's never a good sign when you see
the you know the double pawns it means
he takes B3 has been played uh yeah I
know you know that's that's not the way
you usually want to capture so uh really
really good start for Jeffrey and you
kind of mentioned that he he would
likely go for a position that gave him
some chances he's not just trying to
make a draw and call it a day and I
think that's exactly what we see on the
board here
I I actually will say that I think
bortnick's decision to not take the
Berlin draw when he had that chance is a
strategic mistake given Who board Nick
is a chess player and how good he is of
the black pieces boarding's got his
systems worked out they worked for him
in the first game I think a draw here
would would put him oh so close uh to
winning this match now he's staring down
the barrel of essentially a lost
position in the middle game he's down
four and a half minutes Jeffrey has to
find a way to convert this
for sure yeah there's no doubt about
that hindsight of course is 2020 if
you're looking at this position then
you're like yeah give me that drop yeah
I'll take that draw I'll take the draw
for 200 Alex
now this this doesn't look comfortable
at all Bishop on A6 so strong D takes on
uh E4 is a big threat right now because
it's actually gonna be followed up
um by Bishop to D3 and then Knight takes
on e4 which is just so unpleasant
so white should probably go Rook 81 here
but that just puts a Band-Aid over the
problem it doesn't solve the underlying
issues of why it's positioned black has
a million ways to improve his position
Queen B6 Rook C8 Jeffrey playing
confidently quickly and hitting that E3
Pawn where it hurts
yeah and the thing is he doesn't even
have to spend 10 seconds calculating
Queen B6 it's just it's a good move he
knows where the pieces go white is back
under the gun here
as the overused expression goes the move
plays itself
if fortnite pulls a draw out of this
this would be the ultimate miracle
and the same probably goes for Fabiano
caruana who is similarly suffering
craftive as a Pawn on B5
man not much to say here in Black's
favor this this just sucks I mean the
the Knight got to E6 so I'm actually now
wondering what night that was
you know it's like which Knight is on A5
exactly but weird position for Fabiano
he he has this like long-term dream of
maybe B6 Knight C5 Bishop B7 but
the thing is you're just not going to be
afforded all those moves at once that
that's just not going to happen so what
you're left with is a bishop on C8 that
can't develop and this Knight on A5 that
is requiring so much attention right
Queen is actually strangely not on E2
it's on E1 so there is an x-ray idea of
hitting that Knight on A5
yeah there is obviously but that's if it
hits the knife it's it's hard to
engineer that though because if you play
Knight E4 prematurely then you're
actually giving black the chance to
swing the Knight around to C5 on the
other hand maybe you want to allow this
and then do something like I mean you
can see that the Evo bar has not dropped
okay did drop with that move so maybe
bishop C5 and B6 should be considered I
really think if white does anything on
the queen side it's going to end up
being good just because of how bad black
species are placed and how advanced
White's Queen side pawns are
I just think that craftive needs to make
a decision quickly because I don't know
if he's going to be able to survive
another middle game where he's got below
a minute on the clock
that's a good point so relatable for a
guy like me looking at someone get low
on time I mean it it really has to be
said there is a big difference here in
the overall level and crafts if he might
just be a player that naturally takes
more time uh he might be overthinking
the current situation but he has
reminded us uh how good he can play with
that low time so that's a redeeming
quality that it's not just like you know
somebody that you don't really trust
with with a low time in a Time scramble
so he's got that going for him but just
like with anything people like to say oh
Alexander Grisha he plays better when
he's low on time he's better than when
he has more time it's just not true no
no it even Alexander grishek would
accept more time if you gave it to him
but yeah Martin craft if he is one to
watch if you want to assemble you know a
list of lesser known Grandmasters uh who
you want to watch if you want to enrich
your understanding of Chess and really
watch them excited players put Martin
craftsv on that list and I think he's
going to be on a lot of players's lists
after this match win or lose he's got
Fabiana Corona against the wall and yet
another game like I said earlier I'm on
nobody has surmounted a 2-0 deficit in
the cgc thus far so Fabi needs to pull a
rapid rabbit out of the hat and he needs
to do it rapidly
yeah he needs to do it in the rapid
portion as well in the rapid portion
yeah all the above as we transition back
to hikaru's game here and I think uh is
it fair to say that the position looks
kind of how you thought it would on 85
Bishop C5 black is uh blockading that
pawn on D7 but the main question is
although the king for white is very
exposed what can black do to actually
push forward because I look at that
Bishop on f8 and I say look
if it can't move if he can't actually
join the game then I'm not feeling this
two Bishop Edge no you called this I
think earlier the fact that the
bishoping out of the game essentially
just totally limits the amount of damage
that black is able to inflict on White's
King the only construction that I see
which could cause any amount of
objective damage other than a Perpetual
check I don't think black will have any
problems figuring out a way to deliver
Perpetual is if you can put the light
squirt Bishop on the long diagonal but
White's basically saying hey Over My
Dead Body I'm Gonna Keep The Queen on
that diagonal but he I was Finding ways
to get this a little bit more
complicated like if you play Knight E3
here you have to reckon with Bishop
takes D6 but according to the computer I
think because the pawn on A6 Falls right
white is going to be able to hold this
position but he's got to see that yep
and even even in these uh positions
start to get a little you know yeah it
can be scary because your Pawn is being
hit and meanwhile the bishop or the
queen could be just a great blockader of
those two pawns on the queen side
and yet again when you're playing Hikaru
every enemy every danger is Amplified
hundredfolds so you see the bishop on D5
and I'm gonna get checkmated for sure
rg2 whereas with someone else no problem
I'm just gonna drop the queen back to F1
if Hikari your mentality is completely
different as Vasquez Ponders where to
put his Knight in this critical moment
could a case be made for Knight B6 or
does that you know does that consolidate
to concentrate too many pieces on the
queen side would you be scared to play
such a move uh so the reason I would be
scared to play it is I look at this
position and I see that black has
Queenie one Queen H4 or queen H5 Queen
D1 I see that a draw is always available
and because I see that if I extend my
pieces a little bit too far away from my
king then at the in the best case
scenario I'm making that Perpetual as
white but in the worst case it could be
it could be a loss so I want to keep my
pieces closer I like his decision to
play Knight E3 I think that was more
practical now the final step is take
that pawn and I think we're gonna be
very close to even territory
I hate to jump around too much but crazy
stuff is happening on both of the other
two boards first and foremost Fabiana
caruana I just spent like the minute
that you were or the 30 seconds you were
talking counting the minor pieces like
again and again and making sure that
Fabi is indeed down a full piece which
he is this one it's a tie over it's
evened up as well Edge
no there's just nothing to say here
we'll jump to the other game white is up
a full piece Bobby had to give it away
to prevent you know the massacre on the
queen side it was a massacre on the
queen side and now it's a full piece up
it should be a pretty straightforward
technical task for and what the heck
happened how did he how did he drop that
um piece I guess it was the Knight on A5
C5 wow
and then he took it and
goodbye Knight
wow that's incredible there's just
nowhere to put it look at that before
Total Domination
thank you very much
and the attack is not diminished yeah
exactly like Martin is not saying okay
I'm up a piece let me just try to chill
out convert no he's going for the throat
again Knight G5 I think he's he's
playing beautifully this match and you
called a 2-0 this looks like it's going
to be a 2-0 for Martin and then Fabi is
in a must-win position from here on out
and that's not the only crazy thing
that's happened Jeffrey Zhang has
frittered away his entire Advantage so
much so that Oak Center boarding is
actually better here what the heck
happened here he gave up a rook for two
incredibly well positioned Knights I
don't get it what happened after Queen
B6 he played Bishop takes D3
Rook takes T6 D takes C4
Rook D6
and just what the heck was 95.
I have no idea
that makes no sense to me
and then you can do Knight D5 maybe he
accidentally knows sometimes it happens
where you play the second move of the
very issue you forgot that you didn't
make the first move right because
there's Queen tasty for no there's
something totally off right like that's
that's just a something that you don't
expect and it's a miracle that Jeffrey
is able to recover at least some of the
material isn't it he he's able to go
Knight F6 but OLX Center portnick is
back from the dead here but he is down
to 34 seconds so it's still very much a
three result game
yep and Ticking down it looks like
um after Rook 88 he's uh he's really
under the gun to come up with a move and
Rook C1 was the choice
wow by the way Quick Draw agreed in the
Hikaru game as we expected
and that is again like you know
definitely good result for Rodrigo he is
the underdog I think he's been quitting
himself really really well in that match
so we'll stay tuned for the conclusion
of that one as well
yeah he definitely has I'm also keeping
an eye on the carwana game because Bobby
is not going gentle into that good night
let's put it that way but we're sticking
on this game for now board Nick down to
18 seconds he has to make sure that he
contains Black's Pawn majority on the in
the center you can't allow like F5 E4
and F4
Knight C1 is the wrong kind of move for
me like F6 uh definitely stands out also
Rook D1 I'm sure that Knight takes E5 is
a little bit too frisky of a move so I I
definitely like F6 that I think Rook D1
and where does that Knight go from C1
it's just like it's stuck
no you called it because if the Knight
moves away the moment the Knight moves
away The Rook slides back to D3 and
starts vacuuming up these
incredibly weak bee pawns eight seconds
for Bortnick
in the longer I don't I don't see this
happening for him I think Jeffrey Zhang
is going to pull this one out
yep
yep time to maybe bring the king or move
the pawns if you're black I think every
piece is pretty much situated perfectly
here
yeah and it's very depressing that you
can improve the position at infinitum
you can just go King F7 H5 G5 bring the
king in and one way or another
eventually something has got to give for
white
you can't sit there while black advances
every single Pawn One move at a time
um the Knight as you said moving from C1
would allow Rook either Rook to D3 track
and the V3 Pawn Falls
yeah
um Jeffrey taking his time trying to
figure out the best way
to improve his position to optimize
his Pawn majority and he does default to
King F7
and it is the hardest thing Amman when
you've got three seconds and you have to
go back and forth that's so much harder
when you have no time on your clock in
92 by by Sasha oh look at that trap let
me show this really quickly if you go
Rook D3 and Rook takes me three Knight
C1 traps The Rook that's amazing I found
this with what two seconds left
right holy cannoli
yeah and it still works if you use the
other rope it doesn't work as well but
it's still a great idea
no it still wins the piece Rook D3 do
not take that pawn
though
but now you're almost getting mated in
so many lines
yeah it's a miracle that King E6 isn't
mate because of Rook C6 check
but Jeffrey could set things up with a
move like G6 here no if board Nick
survives this
then something is in the air today I
mean something's already in the air
today
oh it definitely is it's been the
underdog day for sure in every single
match thus far
King E4 though instead of King F2 means
probably he was very uncomfortable with
the movie E4 from black yes you're
absolutely right although I think after
Knight E1 there
the knights actually don't do such a bad
job of Defending key squares in White's
camp but Jeffrey you know when you've
got a minute left and you're trying to
find Checkmate it's an infuriating
sensation if you're not finding it it's
easy to start panicking yep
I guess you could go King E7 I I'm not
sure
if there's any yeah you could specific
reason to do that like now Rook takes B3
is an idea so
I'm thinking maybe there's a way to move
the king but no white just gives another
check on on C7
Bortnick is an is a magician in these
situations though how many of these
comebacks have we seen from him no time
that position and yet he somehow stays
alive the Rooks are off the board and
Amman I think the time is right for
Jeffrey to start pushing his kingside
pawns so I think we'll see F5 G3 because
white wants to go 92 Knight C4 if the
Knight ends up on C4 at least it's a
solid Square ties black down but there's
no question in my mind you know uh h6g5
E4 what white is definitely worse off
here and Rook D1 is an excellent move
Rook takes D3 I think finishes the game
oh that's a great move that's a great E4
Pawn end game up upon on the king side
and white is way too slow
getting to B5
technically material is equal but
I mean well he can't play 73 because
then the past Pawn gets created but also
King C4 King B5 he knows he's too slow
yeah I think the simplest just go G5 and
H5
just push these spawns create a pass or
distract White's gang it's the classic
portneck is going to go down
what a game by Jeffrey equalizing on
demand
yeah this is going to be just G4
easy okay creation of a pass Pawn
we can switch to the other game because
Fabiano caruana like I said
he is doing everything in his power to
keep this game going both sides under 10
seconds
crafts if still up a piece and his
Knight is heading to E5
yeah you can also throw in like Bishop a
B2 or something just to try to win that
a pawn bishop E5 just as effective
I don't know I don't know about Bishop
B5 though because now
the Knight is less effective at stopping
the passenger but Knight f8 what a move
he takes these six I love it I I think
no you're right he's wrangling punch oh
what a trick what a trick he might lose
that's the only Square that's the only
Square you can't put the Rook anywhere
but there A5 A6 a A4
holy smokes he could lose this he could
lose this game
unbelievable
folks he's actually gonna lose this game
there's still conversion to be had but
that that's just turned around on its
head I can't believe that Fabi can't
even believe he looks upset
Pappy's upset on Martin's behalf he's
like yeah
I don't deserve this and now he just
brings his King somewhere D4 there's no
Fortress here White's Rook has no
anchored squares no
as far as it can he's dead
he's Deborah takes out five Queen E4
picks up the Rook
it's all over wow Daniel lost
yeah this is done
unbelievable Martin craft is well if we
don't witness it on camera he will
literally be kicking himself at some
point today I I can guarantee it that is
the only Square you can't go to Daniel
as you're highlighting some of the other
ones he needed to leave his Rook on the
a file we understand that but
all he needed was a safe Square A4 would
have done it
then you just use the Knight to pick up
the rest of those loose pawns yeah
because here the key difference of
course is that you can play GH and you
can do whatever the heck you want take a
two go Knight D4 you're chilling but
after Rook A3 H4 you can't take the pawn
because of Rook H3 check with a skewer
unbelievable happenings here at the cgc
as both of the top seeds have equalized
the match with the black pieces I can't
believe what we just saw but in any case
Hikaru Nakamura his score is 1-1
everyone scores one one and everything
is yet to be decided come on in the last
two games we're gonna take another short
break you better not be going anywhere
because we are in for a barn burner here
at the chess.com Global Championship
back with the other two games of the
round of 64 matchups in just a couple of
moments
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
[Music]
have we mentioned there's also a million
dollars at stake the total pot is a
million dollars no that it's not a typo
the prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remain it's over wow Ray Robson
eat Chuckles he's not happy but he
respects the legend of ivanchuk and that
Legend Continues The cgc Knockout phase
has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real queen G8 check oh
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
cgc as we have a glimpse here at the
tournament overview thousands competed
in the open qualifiers 32 made their way
through their qualifiers 32 more were
invited as the organizers invites The
Knockout phase began with a round of 64.
after today we will have only 32
remaining a round of 32 will be
contested very very shortly it will
start on this coming Wednesday at the
start of October there will be around a
16 and that in turn will determine who
which privileged few get to travel to
Toronto Canada
to compete in the cgc finals at the
start of November Amman we will be in
Toronto it's going to be a fascinating
final it'll be lit as the young people
like to say but right now what's going
to be even more lit is ikar Nakamura
who has not been able to get the lead
over Rodrigo Vasquez in the first two
games of the match in fact none of the
top seeds have
yeah it's uh it's really really crazy
what we're seeing here I've witnessed so
many different days of broadcast for the
cgc definitely seen some upsets but I
don't think I've seen a day where every
single match appears to be up for grabs
totally up for grabs it should be a 2-0
deficit here
Fabiano caruana instead it's 1-1 he's
breathed New Life meanwhile you've got
Rodrigo completely hanging in there with
Hikaru it's one to one with two draws as
we see their match
getting underway Dania Knight F3 again
from Hikaru
yeah Knight F3 and this time he decides
to fanchetto his dark squared bishop and
whether Rodrigo Vasquez second move he
guarantees Hikaru is not going to be
playing most likely the double field
Kettle setup instead we're going to get
a grudfeld
main line C4
this thing so uh Vasquez with the
I guess uh they they play Queen B3 in
this just making that Bishop on C8 feel
like it has to stay at home a little bit
longer Queen B6 here and you know white
can even be happy with some of those
positions where the Queens come off the
board
this is an opening I know nothing about
because my Pawn is always on D6 as you
know you're like pushing the pawn to D5
is like you know a a brave feat that I
have never mustered up the courage to do
I only played this once and it happened
to be against Vladimir kramnik in a
classical game let's say I chose uh
quite poorly when it came to the type of
player against him you should try a new
opening it didn't really well yeah I was
gonna say you uh you really reserved it
for you know guys I wanted to practice
it against someone you know someone who
isn't very theoretically Advanced first
and then I decided to take it to the big
fish
right no that's that's the way to do it
this is like you keep it in a trophy
case and only bring it up for the very
very best yeah
indeed Queen B3 though has given Rodrigo
Vasquez pause and not a lot of moves in
the opening have given him pause he has
been playing with lightning speed in the
first 15 to 20 moves sometimes to his
detriment
yeah and indeed he missed a chance in
game one because of that but I I think
that he also kind of knows maybe himself
as a player maybe this is just who he is
but I think he's also playing to his
strengths he doesn't want to be in time
pressure like Hikaru is first of all
gonna make anybody blunder in a Time
scramble when he's putting pressure and
you've got the clock working against you
so I think Rodrigo is just saying look
I might miss a few things in the middle
game you know maybe in the opening just
playing a little bit too fast but I want
to keep this pace up for the match
because I don't want to deal with time
pressure at all and I think that's an
interesting strategy because that's one
area where Hikaru beats pretty much
everybody in the world and if you just
don't let yourself get there you might
miss some things on the way but you know
you uh you you take give and take a
little bit so interesting interesting
strategy I think overall it is a
successful strategy and players of all
levels can relate to the incredibly
tilting feeling of facing an opponent
who seems to be playing Super
professional but he must be blundering
there's no way he could be playing this
fast in a position this complex and yet
the blunder never seems to come Knight
bd7 disapproved of buy the eval bar the
main no it's not time to stretch Alex
I'm commentating
um the main move is Bishop F5 here
developing the bishop outside the chain
and then going Knight bd7
I think the drawback here I'm on is that
white is able to quickly push the pawn
to E4 occupying the center
yeah upon the E4 Rook uh D1 Knight C3
this looks like ikaro is gonna be very
happy with how things have developed and
well he's definitely saying I want to
play the move E5 I'm not sure that he
can do that though first of all Rook D1
looks like a great place to start
and where are you going to put your
queen because if you move to C7 it walks
right into Bishop F4 exactly yeah
a little something
yes
feel in the black maybe 90s yeah
this typical Hikaru move I guarantee
hikara will play Knight A3
I have played Hikaru so many times I
know exactly what he will do even before
he knows what he will do
same same concept though a worse move
honestly eval bar disapproves no I
actually think that A3 was yeah
the top move was was actually A4
probably attending Knight A3 actually no
but we're not going to talk about that
Knight bd2 same thing synonyms
yeah heading to C4 and okay E5 once
again not possible so it just feels like
blacks last one two now three moves have
all been to do one single move E5 and
it's still not possible and Carl hasn't
like gone out of his way right it's not
it's not like he's getting a huge detour
and he's got like a you know Queen on F4
and a rook on E3
he's developing normally here yeah he
doesn't have some like yeah orchestrated
all of this thing you know he just
develops his pieces and simultaneously
stopped D5 yeah and this is the first
bad position that Rodrigo essentially
has in the entire match and it's going
to be a very trying time for him the
next couple of moves because Hikaru is
so good at stepping on the gas pedal in
these situations he car senses it he
knows that if you can expand his
advantage in the next couple of moves he
could just wipe Rodrigo off the board so
let's see how Rodrigo handles this
challenge Knight C4 Bishop F4 Rook C1
it's like you know and hand me the most
basic way to develop and it's probably
also
maybe the best moves so ikar is going to
have no issue
um
you know I mean I think he's actually
going to play this position in a way
that could be very boa constrictor-like
he doesn't need to rush he doesn't need
to play like E4 and wow I I love it when
I say something like that and I see the
move H3 thank you that's exactly what I
was saying
your Comet age like a fine wine age
three very slowly Knight C4 and Hikaru
is going to nurture and try to expand
his advantage and as he does that it's a
perfect opportunity for us to stop by
the other two games which have to be
gone
again we can start with Jeffrey against
Alexander a little bit of deja vu here
yeah do you think he looked at uh looked
at this a little bit because Knight
takes C6 certainly not the you know
first move that you look at because you
know that you know black can play B
takes C6 and immediately hit your Bishop
you have to react to that threat
um he played Bishop takes C6 the first
time but engine approves of Knight takes
C6 and this reeks of
um your opening isn't supposed to be
good and I didn't get a good position so
let me fix that
yeah exactly and the bishop drops back
to A4 here
kind of an interesting way to arrange
the pieces putting more pressure on the
C6 pawn and in game one we did see
Jeffrey pushing the spawn up to E5
effectuating
this Central Pawn trade I think he's
still eyeing that and I think there's no
question that white is a pull here right
black doesn't play the Philadelphia and
then claim I've equalized you know black
plays it because he's just comfortable
with the resulting positions I think a
lot of people have a hard time
understanding that you know you can play
openings to equalize objectively but in
the rapid time control I think it's far
more important to play something that
you aren't comfortable with and whose
ideas you know well
yep that's a great point when time is
lower you want to be more familiar with
your environment and there's nobody more
familiar probably with this opening and
the alaka and then Alexander boardnick
so he's once again bringing it out it
worked really well the last time but
Jeffrey clearly has looked at what to do
improved on the first game do you think
he's gonna leave that Bishop on A4 so I
wonder let's say Rook B8 happens on the
board do we play like B3
or maybe even
Bishop B3 because if the bishop goes
back to B3 then I kind of wonder why did
we go to A4 and not C4 earlier yeah
well there's like the mental yeah the
mental pushback I have to be three is
that you almost never play this movie
because of B7 B5 but the vestiges of the
b-pawn are still dissellating me from
playing this move but you pointed out in
game one that it also
uh weakens the entire long diagonal so
black could even consider something like
you know Knight G4 and Bishop F6 maybe
or yeah I don't know if you could move
this bishop away from D7 and put a
knight there reshuffling the minor
pieces in order to occupy the long
diagonal with the dark squared Bishop
could be something to consider but I'm
going to go out and limb and say that
Jeffrey actually will play B3 in the
event of Rook B8
yeah I I think it's it's uh it be three
reeks of aha I've prepared this move and
it's weird you know stack fish Yeah Boy
gotcha we might see B3 like quickly
M5 quickly so this still reeks of
preparation but a difference
absolutely
um really cool idea not only does the E5
Bishop if Pawn takes not only does that
eyeball The Rook on B2 should you play
Rook takes B2 but also Bishop B3 after
Rook takes B2 and you actually kind of
get stuck in there
yeah the Trap closes Bishop B3 comes and
Knight D or a anywhere like literally
any square is good they win the exchange
on B2 so Sasha is probably not going to
take on B2
now before making that decision he's got
to decide whether he takes on E5 in
contrast to the first time Jeffrey play
85 here I think there's maybe a slightly
stronger case to be made for a move like
98 as passive as this move appears black
center is surprisingly resilient B2 is
still hanging so I think Bortnick is
seriously considering the Alternatives
but my guess is that he's still going to
take on E5 what about nice
okay can we try to like simplify
everything
this is like an interesting way as black
to say okay I'm you know comfortable
with a draw it is somehow so I take
everything and then you just take B2
yeah
this already is equal because you can't
trap
this is the moment you like Raise Your
Voice for like five octaves yeah exactly
it's like that moment when you say the
position okay yes
I think that as the position equalizes
The Voice goes up it's a very deep voice
when you have an advantage like yeah I
should have no idea what you do here but
it's almost equal you know so that's so
right that's like the classic like
Eastern European chess player interview
it's like okay
yeah
you're totally right I think you see
this with like Victor Cortina interviews
too
and has he played it as well
or was that as he played yeah
okay the current position is after E5
he's still thinking gotcha yeah Knight
D5 looks like a big consideration here
uh otherwise your move Knight E8 if he
wants to leave more on the board more to
play for now but 90 it sucks it's way
too passive and
as Alexander Bortnick Ponders his next
move in this critical moment we are
going to switch to the Fabiano caruana
game and yeah let's see it what haven't
we seen in the car on a crafts of match
in the first two games
well I think what we have seen is a
queen's gamma Decline and they are also
repeating the same opening from game one
but not the same variation
yeah I was wondering how the heck this
Knight got on H4 but obviously black
must have brought the bishop to F5 white
said okay no no Knight H4 let's not have
that and then white got his own Bishop
to D3 but at the cost of some valuable
time right spending time on Knight H4
and I backed F3 yeah you get your Bishop
there but it's given Martin time to play
the move Knight to E4 just use the other
hand it usually is but I think Martin
may have bitten off a little bit more
than he can chew here now the typical
way that you treat this Knight on e4 by
treat I mean remove is you move the
Knight away from F3 and then you push
the pawn up to F3 and if that happens
then at the end of the day black is left
with these very kind of I wouldn't say
weak but a bunch of semi weaknesses in
the center and of course white also has
the corresponding Outpost 95.
yep
absolutely 95 F3 and white often tries
to play 95 F3 with the pawn on F7 and
then the Knight gets kicked out of E5
eventually but as you said that's now
White's Outpost and when you play this
sort of Stonewall The Stonewall moves D5
F5 to support a central Outpost what
you're doing is you're handing over the
E5 Square to your opponent permanently
while meanwhile like if you look at
White's position I can play Pawn F3 so
white has the E5 Square totally in their
control but black doesn't have the E4
Square just for them so it's not really
uh you know a balanced uh a balanced
trade there
yeah that's a great point there is an
asymmetry in both sizes control of these
corresponding squares
I'm fully expecting F3 from Fabi I mean
this move is not without its positional
risks obviously you're weakening the E3
Pawn sometimes black is able to
Counter-Strike with G7 G5
but and maybe even here G5
yeah the evil bar didn't laugh this out
of the park so
maybe that's something Fabi has to
reckon with
yeah G5 and you know Pawn takes E4 just
a total mess honestly F3 is on the board
by the way so once again maybe I won't
have to play any of these moves yeah let
them let them analyze the position for
us
let them calculate we will sip our
coffees and watch the action unfold but
the psychological undercurrent of this
game I'm on Martin craftive has to find
a way to push that tragedy that befell
him in the last round I mean he was up a
full piece in the end game I don't think
I've ever seen a situation go south that
quickly
it's so true like in an end game things
usually get more clarified and it
absolutely was he had done things
beautifully he was just not even
thinking about the possibility he could
be worse and that's when it really just
blindsides you right when you're not
even considering you could be worse all
of a sudden okay I'm not winning I'm
drawing all of a sudden oh I'm not
drawing I'm lost and that happened in a
matter of two moves so I just hope I
think he's put that you know in a a
different uh a different room close the
door and focus on his math he did I
think he walked out of the room right
after that game I would have walked out
of the room and you would hear the
punches from South Carolina but what I
was going to say is that you know when
you when you encounter a move like H4
after Rook A3 your stomach literally
leaps into your throat your throat just
closes and then you just can't think
straight because craftive still should
have drawn that game and guess what he
still would have been up a point for
this match to be tied is absolutely
really crazy and I think the opening has
been largely successful for Fabi he
decided against G5
and that gives Fabi I think essentially
what he wants out of the opening control
of E5 and some pressure on the F5 Square
I think he's slightly better
yeah and uh also the move Bishop takes
F5 is it's really going to put black out
because then all of a sudden the E6
square is so weak so when you think
about how to defend this G6 comes to
mind but also takes a knight D7 I feel
like he's a little bit of a nicer way to
do it pawn to G6 by black not always a
great thing sometimes you can even meet
Pawn to G6 with pawned G4 or Pawn to E4
oh open up the position right especially
when black creates these permanent
weaknesses on the king side
yeah now Fabi has to decide where he
puts his bishop and whether he even
moves it away because F4 is absolutely
not out of the question you'd rather
have a knight on E5 but you know a
bishop is the next best thing
yeah I think he's gonna go F4
yeah after F4 let's say that
um black goes Knight F6
there's a couple things
oh sorry yeah yeah that the pawn is
hanging there I wanted to say that if
the Knight gets in E4 you know white can
like take that piece and even though
black takes back
there's no pass Pawn whereas if black
takes on E5 white takes back and gets a
protected pass Pawn going up the board
just because of the differences in the
pawn structure Pawn on E3 versus Pawn on
C6
and it's interesting the email bar is
only giving 0.2 but you know sign me up
for this point too any day of the week
92 Knight F4 you pointed out the idea of
G2 G4 that is absolutely in play here in
fact just to illustrate the concept yes
this is premature here but the point of
G4 is to strike at G6 the bishop is
undefended and Black's entire kingside
is liable to collapse so I think Fabi
has done a great job of getting sort of
a tilting type of position to have after
you've lost a game in a manner as
disappointing as he did right but we
will keep an eye on this middle game as
it unfolds as Martin craftive tries to
come back from that tragedy that has
just befallen him in the meantime Oman
shall we go back to the ikar Nakamura
game yeah let's let's see what has
happened there since we left it because
it looked like the Hikaru Nakamura show
goodbye Rodrigo
it's over
um yeah where did the pieces go honestly
I can't say I'm too surprised I don't
know how black would have played this as
we can see the pawn on E6 is kind of
like uh it's like a tombstone of the E5
idea it's sitting on E6 which just means
yeah ee5 never happened it probably was
the reason that his position was worse
when I was looking at the grunfeld with
my friend a couple of years ago I didn't
never ended up playing the grunfels
except against kramnik uh he told me
there's one rule that you need to abide
by in the grundfeld at all times you
never want to have a Pawn on E6 and you
never want to have a Pawn on C6 the only
time you push your ENC pods is to the
fifth ring and it's actually a pretty
good Compass by which to judge the
position now the only consolation here
in monfour Rodrigo is that he's got the
potential to exploit the light squares
along the diagonal but he doesn't have
The Supporting Cast I think to actually
follow through on it he can play Bishop
B7 but how is he gonna get a queen to D5
the car is not just going to allow that
right maybe he's gonna play a five and
win
at F6 Maybe
D5
but even if you allow it okay you play
F3 big man that's right yeah
it's a good point it's a one move thread
Bishop B7 is on the board
I think we're gonna see A5 by Hikaru
yeah and both both sides managing their
time well here so it's not gonna be I
don't think time is going to be a factor
it's just purely on the board here
no Hikaru has done such a good job I
think of adjusting his opening strategy
not a coincidence among that he played a
main line in this game I think Hikaru
realizing that you know the sidelines
weren't working that well they didn't
work well in game one and Hikaru knows
how to play main lines I mean that's
what he does In classical chess and you
know I talked about I've talked about
this with feta save that good friend
um Hikaru is so good at adjusting his
strategy during a match he's not
stubborn he knows exactly what
adjustments he needs to make he's like a
good football quarterback you know maybe
I'm throwing too many long passes maybe
I'm throwing too many short passes
Hikaru does that like clockwork
yeah there are some uh players who let's
say they they only play made knives only
play Sidelines the thing about players
that play Sidelines especially when
they're as good as Hikaru is is that
they're doing that because they're
already so good at the main lines you
can't get away with playing Sidelines
the way Hikaru does without being an
expert at the mean lines first that's
not how it works so when you see him
doing that it's not because he doesn't
know what's going on in the main lines
it's because he absolutely does know
what's going on and that's the reason
why he can he can deviate that's a great
point and uh I think this game is going
to end within a couple of moves Knight
takes B6 excellent tactical Vision by
Nakamura Rook takes A5 Rook C8 drops the
queen we can pull up an analysis board
here just to show all of the sidelines
Bishop takes B1 Knight takes A8 and the
bishop hangs and if you try to drop the
bishop back and say the Knight is
trapped it is far from trapped it can
evacuate back to B6 now if you take
twice Rook C8 the classic Bishop H6 ends
the game
beautiful it's all over it's all over
and Vasquez should be resigning this
within a couple moves and if Knight
takes B6
that looks like
the first move I would think of just
because if you get Rook takes B6 then
you could try to take on A5
yeah I think that was the most resilient
he does end up taking on B1 and I think
yeah probably very similarly
maybe he wants queen takes A5 but then
Rook C8 check and the queen takes the
bishop you've got two pieces of line of
the first rank yeah that's a nice detail
but I think Hikaru knows that he's
definitely secured the full point in
this particular game
um Queen takes A8 and
we see yeah Queen takes A5 okay but that
Knight on D5 uh give me H5 you know I'm
I'm a guy that needs maybe like five or
six moves here yeah totally happy yeah
exactly no once you get a knight to D5
it's actually not gonna be that easy I I
forgot the black and play Queen takes a
for whatever reason so no because Rook
E8 is covered
the plus six here could be a little bit
misleading I think it's plus six just
because black is not able to get the
Knight to D5 the moment you play Knight
F6 you run into this check on B8 and
White's just gonna Massacre the minor
pieces of the queen C6 maybe D5
too many Avenues too many threats
that's really important to notice that
though that that the Knight on D5 is
actually the the key for black because
the engine is going to give like a crazy
high evaluation oh yeah now you can't
get to D5 but for a human to sit there
and realize oh that's why my position is
so good Queen F3 by Hikaru you want to
also play Rook B7 King G2 the F7 Pawn
will be targeted and I think Hikaru is
gonna be very comfortable
yeah and the king is perfectly safe with
plenty of lift
yeah we're the result of this game is is
not in question Hikaru never screws
these kinds of games up yep okay yeah I
think we can trust him to convert his
totally decisive advantage and let's do
the rounds once again let's go to the
Jeffrey Bortnick game which continues to
heat up in that philador
and what is going on here so he does
have a Pawn on B3 he just put it there
so we saw Rook B8 B3 but a little bit
later than we thought we would see it
yeah I think you know that was one of
those things I was uh
kind of expecting that might have been
part of his prep just a general concept
not like oh I gotta play B3 but if the
brook ever goes to B8 then I'm kind of
meeting it with the move B3 so
interesting interesting funny comment in
the chat Rodrigo looks like Saul Goodman
yeah I can kind of see that actually now
that you point that out
now I feel like whenever you say that
somebody looks like somebody else
there's like a group of people who are
like militantly again like no there's
like no resembles at all like what are
you saying you know what I'm talking
about I see the curvature and I've
examined the eyelashes and you know I've
devalued the comment and it's not
acceptable
now the board next Bond structure on the
queen side is also not acceptable and
yet I think the the compactness of his
position somewhat compensates for the
damage spawn structure I still think
he's worse though and if he's not
careful you could just get you know
white could just disappear the entire
Queen side here in the blink of an eye
yeah Queen C7 is the C7 Pawn is actually
it doesn't look like it maybe right now
Queen A7 reminds you it's the glue that
that holds literally the whole position
together
it does and by the way if you play Rook
ecn and say all hands on deck you're
actually plundering Rook takes D6 and
queen takes how easy is that to blunder
yeah seriously
a pawn is loose there's tactics on D6
however the I feel like the engine is
just not phased like doesn't care about
Queen A7 at all I'm I'm in panic mode
well Rook takes C1 and queen D2
flashed uh flashed in my mind initially
and then I realized you're blundering
the other Rook with check that's right
that's out of the question okay he took
anyone but he goes Rook B7 interesting
what's going on I was gonna say isn't
there 94.
and there's no Queen D2
but there is Queen E5 or queen E7 and
black holds on by the skin of his teeth
I don't think that's gonna that's
sustainable though like Queen E7 even
rookie three
yeah I wanted to go Queen d uh Queen D4
after Queen E5 as like a way to play
Rook a seven strangely
oh
oh and there's also the Perpetual idea
Queen D1 agree H5 exactly yeah exactly
so like rookie three Queen D4 actually
makes a great impression
yeah that's a really tricky defense so
maybe here
White's move should be
some sort of
yo other than rookie three how else are
you going to can you ensure that the
Knight can move
how's that end game it's not good right
I imagine my takes D6 is just ridiculous
let's pull up an analysis board take a
look Queen takes C1 King H2
I think black could just move the Rook
ah yeah that's a good point you're
excused but that's what you got to try
in these types of positions right I mean
you got to leave no stone unturned when
there are this many pieces that are all
kind of hanging yeah
yeah so let's yeah rookie three I think
Queen D4 is the Saving Grace
so you redeemed Yourself by finding the
smoke there okay got one got one right
you were close there so getting kicked
out of the commentary now that you found
this perpetual
yeah what is the move it's like plus
three
but I I actually have no idea
um
I thought runs into Bishop F5
because what we're starting to see oh
Bishop 595 yeah oh
Queen d8
oh when Bishop takes C6 and talk about
the glue him on if you slide The Rook up
you lose C7 we know what happens when
you lose C7 you lose the whole game
wow
yeah Queen d8 is this uh great move and
it's been played on the board
Jeffrey went into the tank there and
came up with Queen d8 ortnick does not
look happy to see that move no he does
not and you want to hear something crazy
this is a really cool detail now anytime
black tries to give the same Perpetual
white is going to have Queen to H4 so
that is another positive byproduct of
the move Queen d8 maybe bishop E8 is the
best defense but now in comes the F Pawn
F4 Queen D4 check King H2 and look just
lacks entire position the the geometry
evaporates here it's beautiful you can't
move the Knight you can't move the
bishop The Rook is stuck in molasses
this one is completely winning for white
you know it's so rare for
let's say the opposing player to have
their Queen on your back Rank and then
you still have Rooks on the board that
are not on your background like you're a
rook on B7 it's like wait a minute whose
house is this like what's going on yeah
home invasion is happening
and the White Queen
just on its own is holding off Black's
entire Army of rook and minor pieces
I don't see a single way for Alexander
Bortnick to avoid just Mass loss of life
and gnashing of teeth here
yeah we've looked at a few different
we've looked at almost every bishop move
yeah Bishop E8 Bishop E6 Bishop F5
um I mean Bishop
G4 I guess is the last one I mean you
can still play Bishop C6 still Bishop C6
yeah
I think it's over not to mention of
course that he's got now a minute and 45
he goes Rook B4 but this these
situations are when Seahawks in aboard
Nick has pulled off crazy comebacks
yeah
yeah I looked at the ribbon before and
I'm like I just want to play C4 here oh
yeah totally I just it just feels good
shut that thing out and
great minds think alike
Ah that's a really unpleasant move as as
black because let's say you play Rook
before in order for him to even play
that move he probably had to calculate
so many things like just to justify it
and then his opponent calm cool
collected doesn't care spends four
seconds uh C4
down to 90 seconds
lados Lounge was asking what happens
after Knight takes E4 well the problem
here is that white grabs sorry
white grabs the bishop on D7 that is the
product Queen f4101 and you're basically
just losing all of your pieces Bishop
takes E6 Queen takes F7 just general
societal collapse here happening among
Black's ranks oh a knight F6
so you can't use an extra cake great
little uh great little sound effect
there Daniel that was a perfect one you
know I've started to judge my own whoops
that one was like an A plus sounded
really really it's kind of like when you
you high-five someone it just comes out
so crisp oh yeah I know that or a snap
yeah you can't snap but when people who
can't snap snap
right okay Queen takes C7
um
right because previously with the Rook
on B7 we were looking at Bishop C6 here
but now Bishop C6 at least doesn't hit
the Rook which is kind of an achievement
for uh black
yeah Bortnick is somehow rearranging his
pieces in such a way that making them
very difficult to actually bring down
what if you go a three
I guess the Rook drops back to B7 then
because then Bishop C6 Rook B3
yeah exactly crazy because you move the
seep on and now you move the a pawn and
suddenly the mini Pawn the least likely
to be weak ends up being captured
um
your car has one by the way
just to make sure yeah so he's ahead in
that match now two to one must win final
rapid game for Rodrigo but we'll stick
here for the for the moment this looks
like a really crucial moment here for
Jeffrey it feels like there's like maybe
one or two final nails to put in the
coffin so to speak
um and if he finds the hortics in real
trouble they talk about resilience talk
about defensive ability fortnite has
somehow I mean I felt like I looked at
every single move on the board and they
all look lost and somehow he's created a
situation where I don't see the
Breakthrough
and he's making it look easy with 45
seconds on the clock I think Alexander
boarding is maybe like one of three
players and he's in pretty good company
car Nakamura I mean I would probably put
like Magnus in that category who can
literally just come out of any situation
alive doesn't matter how much time they
have on the clock doesn't matter how
lost they are they're always going to
make it difficult for you and upon
further reflection of on I think the
most sort of you know the executive
decision here should be Queen takes C7
trade queens and go Knight C5 and
basically vacuum up all the flax Pawns
this I think is the simplest way to win
but it's just so interesting because
when an engine evaluates something it
could say plus three but they're plus
three in some lines it means you're up a
piece in other lines the position is
just so bad that it's plus three but for
a human I'll take this plus three as
Black versus down a piece plus three so
when you're calculating as Jeffrey I
don't think you're evaluating those two
things as identical you're thinking oh
wait I must be missing something this
feels totally winning and all I'm
getting is an end game where I'm maybe
I'm gonna win a pawn but you're pointing
out that's exactly what you should be
transitioning to now you're exactly
right and there's these mental blocks
you have to overcome
Jeffrey Zhang just overcame them yeah
there he goes That's super impressive
um just to understand that hey my
opponent has wiggled out of this uh it
does work but I'm still gonna be able to
to end up on top in the end game and
yeah this this is a dominant end game
for Jeffrey let's see if he can well it
would be crazy come back right down one
nothing now putting himself in a
position to actually win this match the
funny thing is that material is
currently equal currently equal
currently and the eval bar is giving
over plus five in white sense that's
insane it is insane and if you're
struggling to understand why like just
the point is that black is going to lose
at the very least two pawns and probably
also the A5 one so you know in in the in
the short term and the next three moves
it's hard to understand why it's so
winning but look at the long run white
is going to vacuum up all of the pawns
and barring a miracle barring black
somehow coordinating The Rook at night
to create counter play this one should
be basically in the back for Jeffrey
he's also got three minutes excellent
time management uh throughout this match
by the way by Jeffrey Jean
yeah I mean you said look if you're
struggling and understand what
immediately I was listening I was like
yep that's me I'm struggling to
understand why this is plus five but
you pointed out every Pawn is falling
and if you look at the coordination work
on b49 on F6 where can you put those two
pieces so that they actually you know
post some some threat to White's King
and I can't even find an arrangement the
F3 and G3 and G2 pawns are just perfect
no they're they're great they're like a
bumper on a car you know you can get it
to a fender bender won't damage the body
of the vehicle
that after repon Robert Hess would be
pointing out that it upon and a knight
on the same file two squares between
them the worst possible arrangement for
the night it's like a spike when they
used to bury vampires they'd put spikes
there on the grave right so you'd get
impaled when you Rose from the grave
that's what this reminds me of that
that's a History Channel yeah when they
design chess they have that in mind
Danny they totally had that in mind in
fact Dracula participated
who Vlad the Impaler participated in the
design of Chess but speaking of which
Jeff removes that pawn
I don't know about that Iman I thought
if it ain't if it ain't broke you
shouldn't fix it I was not trying I was
not trying to move my uh my Pawn to F5
the one thing weirdly is that
if you move the Knight there follows
Bishop E8 to G6
it's like kind of nasty you're going for
mate but then white gets this like
coffin
yeah you can't do it but I can Rook
takes A5 Jeffrey is just vacuuming up
all the pawns he's like I don't care
it's like that scene in Groundhog Day
where he's eating all these donuts and
the day resets and she asks him yeah are
you not worried about cholesterol at all
nope Jeffrey just collecting all the
Pawns
and the king is perfectly safe this
should be pretty easy nonetheless yeah
and I mean we talked about Pawn on F3
covering the two squares for the night
uh I'll take a bishop instead covering
not just G4 and E4 but also H5 D5 even
further whether it's on C6 or F3 the
Knight on G5 has absolutely nowhere to
go cardboard Nick can't even get the
smallest Victory Iman he can't even get
his King to just let me get this no no
no nothing fish King comes to G5 Bishops
another Pawn definitely the most
surgical way to do this stalemate ideas
by the way Bishop G6 King H6 I can
guarantee you that that's what Bortnick
is aiming for
is just punishing
there's nothing here it's amazing how
he's just got no calories it's amazing
to watch 2700s convert positions it's
honestly so satisfying and just look at
this F6
yeah the face that wardnick has and keep
in mind that we just praised and for
good reason fortnite for being one of
the best defenders like in the world and
how he always comes out with something
and you know he's just sitting there
with his his hand on his face because he
just can't move
in basketball good offense beats good
defense you could contest a shot but if
Steph Curry makes a 35-footer then he
makes a 3500 it's the same thing here
Jeffrey Zhang has left Alexander
boardnick with just no chances he has
tried to spark every fire that he
possibly could
but the final position is going to speak
for itself where is that night going to
end up
Rook F7 coming
actually blackstroke is nowhere to turn
yeah it's pretty it gets picked off he's
sad honestly whoa in carwana in the
meantime I thought that the game was
gonna last for a long time but he has
already managed to win as we switch back
to that game
that's incredible honestly
um I I also thought that game would last
for a while I guess strategically it
kind of did
um it was going to be a long game but
Fabi made sure that he didn't close off
every Avenue
yeah he still has that H file he doubled
his Rooks and crafts if just didn't have
enough beef
to put on the file but H4 really
accelerated defeat H takes G3 Rook takes
you three is Checkmate ladies and
gentlemen right such such a difficult
situation for much and crafts if could
have been up two points now finds
himself down one as does Rodrigo Vasquez
as does Alexander boardnick so a turn
for the worse Amman for the lower seeds
they have their work cut out for him
they're gonna have to force arm again by
winning the final game on demand who
will be capable of that
we will see there's only one way to find
out but first a short break as we
prepare for the final game of the final
set of matches here at the round of 64.
the chess.com Global Championship go
absolutely nowhere you will not want to
miss the fourth and final game of these
fascinating matches we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
to anyone
all around the world the chess.com
Global Championship offers the dream of
playing against the best
[Music]
have we mentioned there's also a million
dollars at stake the total pot is a
million dollars no that it's not a typo
the prizes are unbelievably generous we
began with thousands of players now only
dozens remains it's over wow Ray Robson
he Chuckles he's not happy but he
respects the legend of Evancho and that
Legend Continues The cgc Knockout phase
has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real queen G8 check
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends it's the cgc round of 64. who
will take the next step to Toronto
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
chess.com Global Championship we are
observing the final matches here at the
round of 64. at the end of this final
game there will be 32 players remaining
and the prizes that they will be
contesting are absolutely mouth-watering
Grandmaster Iman Hamilton I think these
numbers they speak for themselves don't
they
they do I I think anywhere that you're
gonna find uh you know a million prizes
you're gonna find the best players in
the world competing for them the
champion you can see there taking home
200 000 and of course the largest first
place prize in Pro chess this year Dania
so
um very exciting that uh we have such a
strong field but for obvious reason this
is a prestigious Global championship and
there's tons of uh prizes at stake
indeed and well Hikaru Nakamura has his
eyes on only one of the prizes and that
is two hundred thousand dollars and in
order to unlock the opportunity for that
prize he has to start by winning his
first match against Rodrigo Vazquez who
has given him regardless of the final
game a major run for his money but now
Vasquez with his back against the wall
must win the final game of the white
pieces to force Armageddon and he starts
off with a another pretty tame opening
the same one that brought him a
successful position in game two but once
again I think Hikaru is going to go for
something a little bit more mainstream
this time
yep you called it I think in our last
game when we were talking about how
Hikaru adjusts one of the best uh
players he's not too stubborn about his
openings it's not like he can only play
one opening and then if he gets a bad
position in it he keeps repeating it no
if he sees something he doesn't like
play something uh doesn't really enjoy
the position that he gets doesn't feel
like he has winning chances I mean the
next time he plays that color he's just
gonna switch the opening and that's
exactly what he's done D5 key difference
from the last game where that pawn was
on D6 and even though that game was a
draw I think hikara was like no I don't
want to play that position anymore uh
Rodrigo is sort of going for this zuker
tort kind of idea maybe with B3 Bishop
B2
and uh I think car was more happy to
have the pawn on D5 and just uh you know
instead of the Pawn on D6 he's actually
competing for the space in the center
yeah I mean what Basquez is playing is
sort of the London before the London
this is what people used to play before
they realized that you could park the
bishop on F4 and I think it's one of the
most underrated openings in chess
because it's not very theoretical yeah
you basically play a bunch of moves
really quickly the same ones every time
and if black is not careful if black
just sort of develops in a pedestrian
fashion very often you see why putting
the bishop on B2 Knight on A5 much like
the London and you know the Checkmate on
the king side could come as quickly as
like move 15. you see why lifting the
rook and sacking on H7 you know how many
games like that have we seen even with
strong players getting victimized like
that the black side so Hikaru he's
spending time for a very good reason
interesting Bishop B4 knife what does he
want well the thing is Queen A5 if A3 he
wants Bishop C3 and queen C7 Only
Imagine
94.
very ambitious opening approach by
Hikaru clearly
aiming for the C3 Square no he trades
the knights
I was gonna say
um trying to jump into that C3 Square
too early is a little bit a little bit
difficult
um I think black is happy to have traded
a pair of knights in this position if I
think of you know do I want a knight
thrown on the F6 square and thrown on
the D2 Square here as black my answer is
no so I think I'm happier to have this
if white wants to play 95 now well I was
happy to take that and after Pawn takes
back on E5 there's no Knight on F6 that
gets dislodged right I feel like this is
an achievement for a car or at least
that's why he played it 94 he wanted to
trade those Knights and then continue
yeah he made a significant Tempo
investment in order to trade Knights but
I agree with you I think it's worth it I
think he's largely taken the sting out
of any King side operation that white
can put forward and you can see Hikari
just continues to play in a very
unconcerned fashion he grabs more space
on the queen side eventually the dark
scored Bishop is going to move back to
D6 it can be compelled to move there
with A3 and then he carves placement of
the Pawn on A5 really justifies itself
because anytime that white plays C4 I'm
on you can respond with a sort of
automatic A4 trying to induce more
weaknesses on the queen side maybe not
exactly like this but I think you get
the point
yep and I am definitely surprised by the
move A4
um not a terrible move but uh surprising
because
I mean look at that C3 square if white
doesn't play C4 soon but black will just
play Queen C7 Rook C8 and Bishop C3 so I
don't think that can be permitted at all
so I think are we gonna see the move
either C3 or C4 by white
I don't see an alternative I think you
have to stir things up in the center for
better or worse it is liberating that
white
is in a must-win situation because it
really doesn't give you much of a choice
you're gonna have to push the C Pawn
very very soon
yep we need three I mean if you if you
want to enjoy a tactic or two Rook C8 C3
Bishop takes C3 and it looks like you
know you're the one who's uh blundered
but haha gift to me the pawn yeah so
that's that's kind of one idea of Queen
E3 the other thing I noticed as soon as
uh Queen E3 was played was that black
has the option of playing Bishop A6 I
don't know if it's fantastic right away
but if you could trade off those Bishops
I feel like you'd be happy to do so
yeah positionally no question about it
because white is left with this bishop
that's sort of biting on Gray now Zucker
tour players have kind of a love-hate
relationship with this bishop much like
Yeah The King's Indian Bishop on G7 but
the fact remains I think Hikaru has
largely solved his opening problems and
since he has done so I think it is a
great time to watch the start of our
other two games okay let's start as has
been our tradition with the Jeffrey
Zhang versus all Alexander Bortnick game
uh in which portnick now finds himself
in a must-win situation here we go
seam opening as well
it's a lot of repetition here
um trying to remember exactly what
happened last time but uh it really
turned out well for Jeffrey if we
remember he had a tremendous game C6 B5
A5 but the knights were still on the
board if I recall yeah you're absolutely
right after Knight D4 I think they had
this position and board Nick went Bishop
A4 that's how his Bishop got in trouble
this time he deviates by trading on the
spot and getting his Bishop out to G5
and talking the other Bishop away not on
A4 but on C4
maybe I'm jumping the gun but I do like
this more well I would basically like
anything more yeah what did you do to
the previous game
yeah what are you making this I think
he's definitely done the same thing as
Jeffrey is what I what I believe like
Jeffrey looked at the opening from last
game probably during the slight break
between games as as you should some
preparation it looked like he might have
improved his line I think the same thing
has happened with board neck here
yeah yeah know that you clearly get the
sense that he's
played the moves quickly if vortink is
playing quickly in any position it's
basically because either he has five
seconds on the clock or it's over in
preparation one or the other yep no it's
uh obviously true
if I'm honest you know let's say Jeffrey
plays the typical move D6
okay he's played H6 Bishop page four now
he's played D6 he's kind of ready to
play G5 and shut down the dark squared
Bishop I'm just not
entirely enthralled with White's winning
chances in a position like this it seems
pretty symmetrical black is just so darn
solid in these anti Berlin positions
yeah like Queen F3 to maybe put some
pressure on that night you're pointing
out you know there are some nasty things
that can happen so G5 Bishop G3 and I
swear I've seen this exact thing in
puzzle Rush
oh a hundred times too and there's like
different variations of it sometimes you
can even go Bishop G4 there's a classic
trick right in this position you go
Queen D7 now in this case of course
white has the G3 Square
but the placement of the queen on F3 in
almost all one E4 E5 openings is
associated with a lot of risk yep
yeah that's a good trap to uh so just be
aware of
oh no I'm saying that trap that we just
looked at is a good one to be aware of
because I was thinking oh yeah okay
Queen F3 super logical put pressure on
the F6 Knight and we all know when the
pawn moves to G5 the instinct when you
see G7 G5 is oh that's a weakness around
the king but not always and in this
particular position I think we might
even see Jeffrey play the move G5
voluntarily so I've discovered I've
discovered in doing the speedrun that
people have a path a lot E5 players
that's sort of the club player level
have a pathological fear of making this
move yeah but you have to understand it
like King isn't just automatically
checkmated because you've pushed the
pawn from G7 it's harder than that to
deliver Checkmate and I'm on the same
page I think we're very likely to see G5
and as we wait for the middle game to
unfold in this game a good time to check
into our final game where Martin kravza
finds himself in the same situation as
Bortnick he's got the white pieces but
he is in a must-win situation and I
don't think that he's moving in the
right direction
yeah I think he's tilted he's got over
15 minutes and this doesn't look like
preparation
if it does it looks like preparation
that wouldn't take that long to make
um because yeah Queen B3 you're offering
a trade The Rook doesn't look great on
B3 it's not like it's very well placed
and talk about things being simplified
material being equal no if you're if
you're Fabby here I think you're feeling
very confident that you're gonna draw
this game and thus win the match
yeah the question I have here is why not
Queen takes me through Rook takes B3 and
Rook FC it are you really yeah going to
lose this position I agree that white
probably has a tiny pull here because I
guess these pawns are potential targets
for white trucks but the Rook is getting
into C2 like
you know how bad can it be how bad can
it be exactly exactly with such a bishop
on G7 pressure on B2
um I think Fabi is just double checking
but my guess is that he's going to trade
queens and go Rook C8
yeah strangely enough
um
I think the move Queen A6 is attractive
in a way because
you could make the case that The Rook on
B5 is like you can't really swing
laterally very easily Rook A1 is not
possible and you'll just do the exact
same thing with Rook C8 Rook F to see it
anyway so I'm sure he was giving me some
consideration
who knows who to listen to yeah yeah
exactly he ultimately was like I know
that there's gonna be at least a
division between two commentators and
ultimately Dania will be on my side for
a queen trailer which is totally ironic
you also made an unintentional pun or
maybe it was intentional when you said a
case could be made for Queen A6 Martin
craft stuffchess.com account name uh
handle is
c-a-y-s-e I'm not sure how to pronounce
that but
you know
that's the I actually didn't I actually
don't think I knew that I see that
username all the time title Tuesdays
like winning all these games but oh yeah
that's that's news for for me strong
player very strong player yeah I just
wanted to say that in case you didn't
know
Oh thanks thank you
I was really feeding a dead horse there
H5 by Fabiano caruana so he sort of
keeps the status quo I think he's
basically saying I'm Gonna Keep My Rooks
connected on the eighth rank to avoid
Shenanigans connected if Bishop takes or
Rook takes B6
makes sense
um Rook down to C2 now V2 is protected
so things are a little bit different
White's kind of intending Bishop D6
Bishop A7 if you go Rook C2
um the king could make it up to F3
really easily
bite definitely has a way to expand this
position so I will definitely say I
think this is not a position that Fabi
will lose but I gotta say I probably
didn't give Progressive enough credit
for this one
no he's gonna try he's he's gotten
himself the kind of position where there
is no way to secure an immediate Drive
the game is going to continue but a game
that is very likely not to continue and
this is bad news for uh people who are
hoping for a historic upset it does seem
that Hikaru Nakamura as we switch to his
game is going to hold his own against
Castor let's make it right I mean look
at this position it's plus two for black
oh Bishop A6 is Unstoppable You're Gonna
Lose the exchange you can move the queen
but the Rook is still going to be
trapped
wow
and so oh look at it yeah he's he's got
that demeanor about him where it's like
you know you you can resign now right
yeah we're down here he's got the shable
face
oh yeah the nods are coming in and the
thing about Black's position I didn't
even notice Bishop A6 I was just looking
at the position and I was like okay
Queen D5 Rook C8 sure you know
I feel like tigron petrosion probably
would like see Bishop A6 and still not
play it just because the bishop is so
beautiful
yeah honestly it crossed my mind
no it's totally fair I think you were
never gonna lose if you put the queen on
D5 but with his last move if that's what
hikara wanted to do he would have played
it in this position you can't really
blame him for wanting to win The
Exchange either and then he's still
gonna put the queen on D5 correct
correct any Queens game over so Hikaru
looks like he's gonna do it in
resounding fashion as well he's not just
gonna draw his way but what could have
been maybe a one-nothing lead for
Rodrigo in that first game might end up
as like a 3-1 favorite Victory where you
know if you didn't see how the match was
actually played out with us here live
you might look at that score and say oh
yeah okay Hikaru coasted to Victory but
it feels like it was far from that from
the case no totally in fact if we don't
have a single upset that would be the
most misleading day ever because we were
close to having three offsets now we're
on the cusp of having Zero Crazy how
these matches just turn at the drop of a
hat you know one second you're calling
for the greatest upset in cgc history
the next all of the top seeds just
seemed to wipe the floor
but this one is all over we can leave
Hikaru to it and we can look at the more
combative games let's come back to the
Jeffrey Zhang position because we've had
quite a few transformations in the
jean-bortnick game
right okay and as we make our way to
that position
bad news I'm on bad news indeed for Mr
Bortnick if I'm having the right read on
the position
um yeah Knight G1 never feels great
um I guess the the other thing about
this is Jeffrey has just done a
tremendous job neutralizing fortnite
with the white pieces not even
neutralizing but just out playing him
with black uh fortnite did do the same
thing honestly in his opening early on
in the match but I think Jeffrey has
just recovered and has shown so much
resilience in how he recovered from that
early result in fortnite's favorite
yeah Jeffrey is basically untiltable he
is a consummate professional yeah it
always struck me watching Jeffrey at
tournaments just how first of all how
classy he is we're all fans of Jeffrey
here amazing commentator but you know at
the U.S championship in uh the last U.S
Championship uh Jeffrey had a very rough
start I think he went oh and four but
when I I managed to beat him in round
two
he offered to analyze the game he was
totally
super friendly super nice it's so
refreshing uh like I will fully admit
that like I don't do that like when I
lose a game I'm often not in the mood to
analyze and yeah I can definitely
definitely be a little bit pissy but
Jeffrey just made such a great
impression on me
um because I think chess players uh
really are you know the personality
shines through in those tough moments
when you lose and Jeffrey's just awesome
yeah no that's uh honestly deserve the
summary of pretty much Jeffrey in a
nutshell there King H7 and you know
while he's this great nice awesome guy I
mean he's still gonna play moves like
King H7 and Rook G8 and look to
Checkmate you all right yeah yeah yeah
let's make no mistake he is uh the
baby-faced assassin that is the nickname
for Steph Curry people in chat were
getting annoyed at how many times I
mentioned Steph Curry on a podcast on a
broadcast and on a podcast
but that's precisely why I'm going to
mention him a few more times they don't
know how I work him on no no once you
know that people are bothered by
something now you know what to include
in every every show knife twist that
knife Queen H5 Bortnick trying to twist
the knife on the king side the one
annoying thing for Jeffrey here I'm on
is that you can't go Queen G6 because
you drop E5 and you can't go Rook G8
okay maybe you can but here you drop F7
so he has to solve the problem of these
two pawns on E5 and F7 how is he gonna
go about that
yeah Queen G5 also similar Bishop takes
on F7 so
um maybe is is it just something slower
like okay also Knight F3 is happening
and that e-pawn becomes a Target I was
thinking you could just go slow Bishop
D7 Rook d8 but now I'm thinking with a
knight coming in to F3 I'm not sure how
much time you have
yeah I I think the email bar could be a
little bit misleading here perhaps you
can drop the queen back
and after Knight F3 playoff six but now
you have created a complex of light
Square weaknesses on the king side yeah
which white cannot exploit with Knight
H4 because this traps the queen man this
queen is just having a bad day but maybe
something like crocod1 and it's
definitely a double-edged position we've
got a nice chat message from stranso too
my fondest memory here is getting to
play Jeffrey on a casual stream even let
me get a winning position before
destroying me
nice remembrance there
I like the way more videos memories yeah
exactly they end with and then Jeffrey
like wiped me off the board exactly
exactly I liked your queen G7 suggestion
because it also brings Bishop G4 to the
table and you get this weird idea Queen
G7 Bishop G4 Bishop d8 after Queen H4
so can you say that line again so Queen
G7 with like your move and then okay
just like Pawn A4 just to show uh
Black's kind of threatening like Bishop
G4 and Bishop d8
God the queen has gotten trapped on F3
H5 and H4 isn't it a bad day yeah just
keeps getting worse
so yeah that came to mind
and Jeffrey I think we're we're not
wrong because Jeffrey has spent you know
a solid couple of minutes here Queen G7
is on the board
and board Nick he's listened to us
there's that H3 move yeah he wasn't
having any Shenanigans it's like okay if
I even sniff that the queen could be
trapped let's just end all those
calculations H3 taking control G4 Rook
G8 you might think you have trackmate uh
but Queen takes F7 pins the queen to the
king
that's actually super critical there's
no other way to defend yeah
so Jeffrey is going to have to invest
another valuable Tempo in solving the
problem of the F7 Pawn but like we said
previously that's not easy to do without
making more weaknesses on the king side
could consider F5 but again maybe white
drops the bishop back to D3 there and
goes after the light squares so
I'm going to take back what I said
earlier I I was already starting to
shovel dirt on board Nick but true to
his reputation Amman he has managed to
stir up some Intrigue in this game
yeah I mean there's gonna be Knight F3
Knight H4 Knight F5 ideas you've also
got Rook D1 and you look at that Bishop
on C8 Daniel and it's like okay if you
play Bishop E6 I think White's generally
happy to take
um you know gets rid of the bishop pair
and if you don't play Bishop E6 there's
nowhere else on that diagonal it can go
except D7 so as soon as white plays Rook
81 I'm starting to be like okay wait a
minute how do I even develop this piece
at all
yeah let's start talking about
equalizing well there's the answer
Bishop D7
not you know the sexiest possible square
but and a case in point is that after
Rook 81 Rook ad8
that was a good Wonder though yeah the
queen yeah Queen G5 I'm gonna I'm gonna
let people uh fill in the blank there
figure out where the queen actually
belonged
your wolves are getting a lot of a lot
of power behind the whoops today
I'm perfecting them you know
keep improving as a commentator Bishop
EA is that is that our idea like Rook D1
Bishop back to E8 and then like after
all right yeah I'm not taking ownership
of that idea
I think it's a good idea you might want
to get in as an angel investor okay I
agree I agreement
yeah
F6 and Bishop G6 no I think Jeffrey
actually is
uh has put the time that he invested to
good use
and as Bortnick considers
uh how to deal with that let's switch
back to hikaru's game just to make sure
that we catch the end of that match
and we still have a position with white
being down in exchange I think a draw
for a month
is often what decides positions like
these because at some point the player
who needs to win just realizes that they
have exactly zero chances
so let's use this position as the
example would you accept a draw after as
white
yes at this point I would again Someone
Like You CaRu especially yeah yeah it's
just like it's gotten to the point where
you you know how the match is gone you
know which positions your opponent's
comfortable in I mean first of all I
don't think Hikaru is awesome
he's not accepting but he's also not
offering
um and I I honestly I think I would
probably accept but I'm not sure I would
I would uh I would offer unless it was
very very clear and this position is
pretty clear
okay I think hikaro has has seen the
light I remember in the playoffs of the
uh millionaire chess tournament in Las
Vegas I had a situation where I I needed
to win to qualify to the final four my
opponent needed to draw in the rapid tie
break game I had a lost position so I
basically extended my hand and I was
like all right draw and he declined it
and during the game I got really like
flustered I was like you qualify if you
accept the straw you ended up writing me
yeah exactly takes The Prudent decision
he draws the game he wins the match and
gets into the round of 32. I'm on it was
not easy no that's off to Vazquez
really uh I mean two and a half to one
and a half does actually paint the
picture of how this match was at least
from my perspective here commentating
with you and I think everyone watching
can appreciate that car did not have an
easy Road here Vasquez in the first two
games was neck and neck if not pushing
for more and Hikaru really adjusted well
when he got the white pieces a second
time he made use of them and I thought
he just showed a tremendous ability to
adjust on the Fly and change his
openings play more main lines and
ultimately I think that was what got him
this match went
agree completely that was a great
summary and since this match has
concluded I think we should shift to the
carwana game which we haven't looked at
in a while not all that much has changed
in the carwana game
um well it's still a slightly better end
game for away craftive has this Pawn on
B5 that's fixing Black's Pawn chain on
the queen side
But Ken white actually make anything of
that right you can say that you have
this Pawn
until tomorrow morning but that's how do
you win this position and I tell you I
know it's not the fastest plan ever
executed but King E8 King D7 King C8
King B7 A6 like all right six at the end
yeah like I could just and then suddenly
I have an outside pass Pawn I might even
get optimistic outside password
just outside
yeah it's as opposed to an inside pass
Pawn
I hate those you know when they're
faster as well the e-pawn and the d-pawn
they have the inside track that's right
the queen in seven moves the the tilting
thing about playing white here is that
your king is so far away from the action
it's like the nearest nightclub is 50
miles away like you are not even getting
to
you know D2 by the time the plexing is
already on B7 how do you put up with
this plan right now you could put a rook
on A6 but the secondary issue I'm on of
black getting the king to B7 is that
even if you don't get a chance to push
your a pawn you free up the rook and if
the Rook gets to D5 you could end up
losing the spawn in a heartbeat it
becomes you know it goes from a strength
to a weakness yeah you know at the drop
of a hat
exactly you move the Rook from A2
suddenly A6 uh can be played you leave
it there then black can execute this
plan meanwhile I always start to pay
attention to the pawns and what colors
are starting to get fixed on especially
with the Bishops and black spawns look
very very uh very good on light squares
considering we have dark Square Bishops
in play
yup
and here comes the Kang Fabius just
closing his eyes and getting the king to
B7 nothing more infuriating than a
situation where your opponent's plan is
so obvious that even my cat could do it
yeah and you're sitting there like
you're sitting there okay great I know
what you're gonna do but you also can't
stop it and you don't know how to react
to it so it's like might be obvious but
it's good
I think Martin is trying to stop it but
after King C8 I'm not sure exactly what
he has in mind if he goes rookie four
that's easy to defend against if he goes
for D4
ah let's let's play the moves on the
board King C at F5
let's say I just keep
right parroting the plan
so I don't know takes and like rookie
for rookie six
I'm so let's listen okay double edged
position yeah and that's the best that
you can do is get a double-edged
position yeah six or q6 Black's gonna go
a five but I agree at least in a
situation like this you're up a pawn you
can go after the H Pawn and it's
anybody's game yeah yeah and look I'm
the kind of player I don't know if
everyone's like this I'm the kind of
player that if I'm in a match and I have
to win the game I will take some some
risks uh and risk losing the game
because I mean what's the difference if
it's a three one this is the Jessica
Global Championship like this is a
knockout you may as well leave it all on
the table here I think in the World Cup
which is the sort of most prominent
knockout tournament rating
considerations do play a role you know
like sometimes you don't just want to
lose a game especially if a low-rated
guy is playing a higher rated guy you
often see the higher rated be a little
bit more reluctant to give up you know a
quick draw on the second game for
example here there's no rating on the
line so yeah you know there's absolutely
no reason to pull any punches to hold
back for sure anything if you're on the
side that needs to win to stay in the
match and we just saw uh we just saw
Hikaru take a draw to win the match
right it's like not like there's any
reading considerations obviously you may
as well just you've earned it at that
point and both players can agree that's
a fair result so we do have a an attempt
here by Martin I think that's the way to
do it you're down a point I love it F5
Rook H4 he's imbalancing the position
he's saying you can get a pass Pawn on
the B file as black White's gonna get
one on the H file
I love what Fabi just did here flexible
approach to this position there's no
longer any need to move the king to B7
right the point of that was to prepare
A5 but now White's Rook is on the other
side of the world it's in karth so you
can play A5 without the services of your
king and instead he repurposes the King
as a Defender
love it yeah this is great because now
you can just play A6 you need the king
there the rook's not on the a file
anymore for white so A6 Black's gonna
take it start pushing that beep on
um so I think we'll probably see that
right now
maybe A6 or K4 is there a case to be
made for that
then it's actually you know good for for
white to have I think it might be yeah
I think it might be maybe I'm crazy but
something like this maybe Rook C4 maybe
you start pushing the H Pawn
I feel like White's got a shot here yeah
Rook C4 book C6 yeah and as white you're
probably happy just to have more
imbalances so if you're gonna do
something like this maybe A5 just first
yeah saving a Tempo mm-hmm
I think that's exactly what Fabio's
trying to decide A6 or A5
but I don't think A5 has any downsides
as you're saying right
right
because it forces white too
because A5 threatens A4
exactly and if that happens it's too
much so white needs to take or play
Roque for
he took on passant automatically
okay so this is his idea he wants to
limit the mobility of the pawn that way
still some chances for why no question
about it H4 is coming if I had to pick a
side I would be picking white any day of
the week
yeah Rook B5
um next will be really annoying so I
think it's important that black actually
moves the king now if you imagine that
white stroke is already on B5
isn't black like stuck like the king
can't move any closer to the B Pawn
because the F5 pawn and The Rook can't
move from A6 he's the B Pawn and neither
can the bishop right so it's weird but I
think you need to move the king so that
you can meet Rook B5 with like an E6 for
example great minds think alike King F6
is on the board the other thing you
could do
is to meet Rook B5 with Rook A5 if need
be to dislodge The Rook because any Rook
trade right I think I'm on unless unless
I'm misunderstanding the position any
Rook trade is going to be in Black's
favor it's basically going to result in
an insta draw
100 yeah Rook A5 is a great resource as
well yeah of course Fabi should not lose
this game I mean if he can keep the B6
Pawn alive if he can prevent White's
h-pawn from like reaching H7
I think black is solid enough here to
make that
on demand draw here and carry the match
yeah not without uh trying though uh
crab said but now okay The Rook gets to
B7 right and after Rook B7 B5 and the
pawn gets to stay on a light square and
how great is this I think I think craft
stuff's gonna play Rook B5 in response
to Rook B7
and then finally start pushing the H but
I think you have to go Rook B5 and he
does right
but Fabi just says congratulations
you're blockading my Pawn I'm blockading
your H Pawn with my king do you remember
when we were talking about how you
should just do nothing sometimes like
fabby's doing that right now and it's a
difficult thing to do he's leaving his
work on B7 bishop d8 and he actually
might just play Bishop C7 bishop d8 or
something yeah
he very well might because the h-bun is
never going to get to H5 unless unless
you recruit the services of Europe but
the moment you do that blackstroke is
perfectly positioned to guide the pawn
the beep on forward yeah
but Fabby adventurous yeah that's like
one of those I can do this move so watch
me do it you know exactly and you can't
take on B6 you can't do anything about
it
right also not really threatening
anything but
it's just the move
so in the meantime it seems like Fabi is
on the way to making the draw we should
check into the Bortnick game because
that game is heating up
or dick is an acute time pressure and he
needs to pull another rapid out of the
Hat
Let me refresh to get the current
position
I think he's going down
yeah that was that was a little
disappointing you refreshed and the
evalvar kind of went down yeah
um but those Bishops plus obviously the
extra extra pawn and Rook d8 stops
Bishop D3 as if we needed any more
reasons to like Black's position but
Bishop D3 is kind of the Annoying move
it's been stopped great chances for for
Jeffrey
yeah really the last hurray here for
Bortnick trying to encircle the king
with his remaining pieces
I wouldn't rule out C5 and Bishop C6
white skin could be the one on The
Chopping Block here
that's a great move C5 and it's amazing
how this e-pawn just steps out of the
way right yeah Bishop C6 E4 E3 and both
spaceships oh what a pretty line
maybe bishop B3 or something just to
show it is Bishop B3 also intends Bishop
C2 but now
I don't think there's any stopping this
and the checks from the Bishops and it's
beautiful beautiful uh coordination
unless you forget we have a rook on f8
that's also hanging which can be picked
up on demand the moment the night drops
back to F3 this one I think is
essentially over 14 seconds for Bortnick
he's it doesn't have a single move here
he might have to take on E8 but if
that's the best that he can do I think
he might as well resign the game yeah I
think he has to
I I think it's worth taking on E8 rather
than resigning even though you're down a
lot of material there is still some
light Square
um possibilities uh but Jeffrey played
this game tremendously
he it was never really in doubt I mean
it was a great opening Jeffrey took his
time when he needed to take it right
Queen G7 F6 finding a way to deploy his
light squirt Bishop yeah and now all he
needs to do is
you know avoid uh catastrophic blunder I
think you can push the e-pawn to E3
right I don't see why not before check
and then King H1 on to E3 and you've
actually got the exact same thread as
before but now the Pawn's already there
yeah and there's a very pretty line I
can show this real quick as Jeffrey by
the way taking his time like the
professional that he is white can try a
last-ditch attempt Bishop D3 Rook takes
he looks like White's still stable but
in comes the epon again after Rook takes
E2 it's a ladder Checkmate you have the
bishop that you need it's controlling H2
and it's all over
E4 is on the board and so is E3
yeah it's so strong four seconds left
what what can you possibly come up with
except
this exact line
and there it is that is the final move
of the game what a beautiful Pawn
Advance I'm on the pawn going from E5
all the way to E2 and it's a mate on H3
I love the decision Rook ff8 Hey if your
mouse slip Rook H3 I've got rookie cheat
me it's a it's a good practical try but
honestly start to finish Daniel I mean
this game was just the Jeffrey Zhang
show even this match after the the first
game I I was I was just so impressed how
he he came back and it was phenomenal
showed the class
yeah he never really gave boarding any
chances in the three games that he won I
mean maybe in the second game that weird
blunder
let Bortnick back in the game but use
the time effectively and Fabiano caruana
is also about to put the finishing
touches on his
amazing comeback against Barton crafts
if this one Amman is probably going to
go down in the books as the most
heartbreaking match that we've seen thus
far the closest one to getting into an
upset territory
wow Martin craftev he's gonna have a
tough build to swallow for the next
couple of days yeah he will and you know
what's actually ended up happening is I
think all the favorites have won their
matches in
boy did it not look like that was gonna
happen nope I would bet you know
my my family heirlooms that we would
have at least one upset I mean it was
like one zero and two of the matches
hikara was barely surviving in the first
two games and yet now it all seems
smooth
exactly
okay now barring Rook blunder this is a
draw
yeah I mean if anything Fabi might win
if you're not careful here yeah exactly
that's one thing to push for a a win or
a result if you need it
um but when you get in the territory
like right now where it's just sort of
needless there's no way to actually make
progress then you're kind of just
tossing away
point
yeah and if I'm Fabi I'm basically
staying on the e-file
yeah which is exactly what he's doing
look back to E4
and this is all perfunctory moves the
result of the game is no longer in
question
yeah rookie King G6
you've seen crazy things happen but
tends to happen the least to players
like Fabiano caruana
I think before it's possible if you
really want to force it true
it's only a question of when Martin
craftive accepts the inevitable here
f for now
yep Abby has two minutes to calculate
that highly complicated line yeah
instead I'm not sure I was gonna say
yeah I'm not sure that was an offer but
probably three-time repetition and
Daniel we have three results in the
books
um quite quite impressive that we saw
three comebacks
um I I still can't get over the fact
that not a single Underdog came away
with even an Armageddon match Daniel
these all finished in regulation
it's absolutely crazy what we just saw
and Hikaru Nakamura he won by the
narrowest of margins but that decision
to adjust his opening strategy was an
incredibly prescient one in game three
he went for a Mainline grunfels Vasquez
wasn't comfortable with it and hikaru's
sails through to a crushing win in that
game again all credit to Rodrigo Vasquez
for an excellent match ortnick and
craftsv they're going to be super
disappointed him on let's be real both
of them stood to win their matches but
you know they can be proud of the fight
that they put up there is a reason that
people like Jeffrey and Fabiano are in
the Super Grand Master crowd as we look
at the overall bracket round of 32 is
set
there it is and finally we have all
names known for the next round I'm
already looking at you know the next
matchups and of course there's some
streamer names that stand out to me as
well some fan favorites as well as just
some Legends of the game some older
places generational differences as well
Dania so man so many exciting matches to
uh to look out for chromic sarin and
Wesley so against vasel ivancic we've
got two major generational matchups to
come in the round of 32 Dominguez
against Eric the Car Nakamura faces a a
David Navara who is playing well in the
rapid in the chess 24 rapid tournament
right now he won his first round matchup
that ain't gonna be easy either for
Hikaru so ladies and gentlemen you're
gonna have to mark out your calendars
you're gonna have to skip some work days
because you will not want to miss the
rest of the cgc
oh my god well what to say I'm on
decompressing after what I thought was
going to be a longer day and look you
know I I might have my my uh players in
the tournament that I want to see do
well yeah I might be a little biased to
see Eric go through but look I always
want to see when I'm commentating an
Armageddon game I'm just I'm a fan of
excitement and we didn't get to see that
today but it was off the back of some
really entertaining games blunders I
think I saw one of the craziest blenders
that I've seen in the competition just
because of the stakes at the time it
would have been two nothing for the
underdog against Fabiano looking back to
that full piece ahead position that
Martin crafts have had so I I that
moment is is a well a highlight or low
light depending on which side you're
looking at
I think that was a great summary I don't
have much to add other than the fact
that your withdrawal your cgc withdrawal
will not last even two days because the
round of 32 begins Wednesday September
21st that is this coming Wednesday the
day after tomorrow at bright and early 4
a.m Pacific seven in the morning Eastern
time and 1 p.m central European Standard
time we will be bringing you the round
of 32 and all its glory and in all its
Force you'll have to tune in to see who
will stay in the tournament and contest
a share of the 1 million dollar prize
fund but for now ladies and gentlemen
the day has come the time has come and
the day has come for us to wrap up our
coverage of the round of 64. today was
the last day Wednesday marks the start
of the round of 32 Grand Master Iman
Hamilton always a true pleasure to
commentate with you this was so much fun
these three hours went by in a Flash so
I'd like to thank you I'm on like to
thank our producer pick for another
Flawless broadcast everybody in the chat
for supporting your favorite player and
keeping the chat Lively and entertaining
and our entire amazing team at chess.com
for the work they do bringing us a high
level and a Flawless production day in
and day out and for now I'm Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski alongside Grand Master
Iman Hamilton selling you goodbye enjoy
the rest of your day hear from the cgc
the chess.com Global Championship we
will see you on Wednesday for the route
32. goodbye
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign